Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Wir begrüßen Euch ein weiteres Mal hier zu logbuch-netzpolitik live auf der Bühne Nummer 300 ist es unfassbar aber wennst hast du dich geschafft 300 Sendung nicht nur zu,
erreichen waren auch wirklich so viele da noch,
bist du diesen Termin produziert zu haben damit das ganze nicht gelogen ist Canada andere Podcast die gehen ein bisschen anders und mit solchen Zahlen aber wir wollen ja nicht über andere Podcast geraten,
sondern ihr wisst ja wir rannten über die Politik und wir rannten,
über die Gesellschaft und die Zustände und natürlich rannten wir auch über den Aktivismus selbst den wir immer versuchen zu begleiten und zu dokumentieren und zur Sprache zu bringen,
und immer wenn wir hier über was machen wir eigentlich hier auf der Bühne was machen wir eigentlich in so einer Gala jenseits des vor Programms nachdenken, eigentlich immer wieder auf den Punkt dass wir
irgendwie herausarbeiten wollen was denn so der Zustand der Welt eigentlich gerade ist und was denn zu tun sei und das ist dann auch das was uns ein bisschen
leitet die richtigen Gesprächspartner zu finden.
Genau denn die Live-Sendungen wird mit wir ja immer unseren Gästen und da wollen wir immer richtige Perspektive,
drinnen haben die wir so noch nicht in der Sendung hatten oder die wir für wichtig für unser Publikum erachten und dieses Jahr oder diese verletzt,
20 Jahre in der Netzpolitik waren ja jetzt nicht immer nur geil.
Die letzten die letzten zwei waren auch gar nicht so geil.
Und wir haben uns überlegt es gibt ja irgendwie Leute die trotz allem obwohl der ganze Planet gerade vor die Hunde geht.
Noch Kraft haben.
Aktivistisch tätig zu sein und irgendwie nicht nur in eine schönere Utopie zu haben sondern dafür auch noch einzustehen und dafür kreativ Zug,
und teilweise mit ganz neuen Konzepten die unsere ihr wie unsere Gesellschaft jetzt gerade erst auch ermöglicht.
EZB dem Internet.
Und mit kreativen und künstlerischen Konzepten und das war die Mischung die wir gesagt haben dass es einfach der der Content für die LMP 300 mit unseren beiden Gästen.
Cecile Leonard vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Und nachher dann mit Klaus Landefeld.
Hallo Jessi.
Jetzt sind wir mal gespannt jetzt müssen wahrscheinlich erstmal noch dein Mikrofon einstellen und so.
So ja ich höre mich sehr gut sagt ihr mal was.
12345 super.
Guck mal für sie machst du das ordentlich.
Ich habe das diesmal nicht gemacht.
Ja da reden wir dann gleich noch mal.
Ja das ist alles ist alles Gute Tessi herzlich willkommen bei logbuch-netzpolitik.
Ja herzlichen Dank für die Einladung ich habe mich wirklich sehr gefreut heute Abend hier zu sein und das Zentrum zu vertreten und da sind wir auch beim. Mit dem Familienduell das Zentrum wäre eigentlich die richtige Antwort gewesen.
Ja das ist das ist glaube ich tut uns äußerst leid erstens war glaube ich relativ klar dass wir die Antworten getürkt haben.
Zumindest die letzten und dann die restlichen Fehler sind Geschichte Klaus Lande Geld kann heute Abend nicht hier sein wir haben nur Klaus Landes.
Und.
Das muss es auch erst mit muss auch erstmal tun.
Wir haben dich aus aus vielen verschiedenen Gründen ausgewählt als als Gast für diese Sendung vor allem aber aufgrund deines dann doch.
Vielleicht nicht ganz geradlinigen und unkonventionellen Lebenslauf der mit dem mit einer Kunstform beginnt.
Die mich immer sehr interessiert hat die ich aber dir sehr viel Mut erfordert und das ist das ehrenamtliche lackieren von Zügen.
Richtig.
Wie kommt man da drauf.
Ganz ehrlich meine Eltern die haben irgendwann aus absoluter Verzweiflung einen Latein Nachhilfelehrer für mich organisiert.
Und der hat mir gar nicht soviel in Latein weitergeholfen aber der hat mir geholfen am illegal Zügel sprühen zu gehen.
Und der wird dafür bezahlt von deinen Eltern zurück und nachher.
Der der wurde der wurde letztendlich natürlich erstmal fürs Latein Nachhilfe geben bezahlt aber,
was mich eigentlich interessiert hat das natürlich nichts mit Latein zu tun gehabt sondern mit der Dose mit der ganzen Hip Hop Szene also ich komme aus Stuttgart,
Stuttgart ist eine extrem langweilige Stadt um aufzuwachsen.
Ist auch langweilig Umsatz.
Auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall,
genau ich bin dort in so einem Vorort von Stuttgart aufgewachsen in schrecklichen Gymnasium gewesen und ja für mich war dann die Hip Hop Szene,
und vor allem dann das sprühende I Moment am so die Grenzen des legalen zu überschreiten aber mit den Mitteln der.
Und am da war es einfach für mich toll wir hatten in Stuttgart damals im Stadtzentrum die Gaskammer die sogenannte,
es war am ein stillgelegter Ampulle der wurde nicht mal benutzt da eigentlich ein Straßentunnel sein sollen und da hat sich so der Stuttgarter Jugendliche Abschaum getroffen,
bei dem ich mich wahnsinnig wohlgefühlt habe das heißt ja Kinder aus zerbrochenen Familien
wir sind dort sprühen gegangen Skaten gegangen sind dort abgehangen erst letztens also shoutout Amrocks ich habe dadurch hatte ein Interview in der Tat und dann hat Rocks mir aus der Haftanstalt
ein Brief geschrieben.
90 muss mal kurz fragen Rock.
Crocs war in Sprayer Kollege von damals den ich jahrelang aus den Augen verloren hatte,
und der ist dann natürlich ganz viel im Knast gewesen zwischenzeitlich und Parts Abonnement und hat mich dann da gefunden und hat mir dann Brief geschrieben.
Ein seitenlangen handgeschriebenen.
Mit Graffiti Schrift.
Ja genau mit Graffiti schnell.
Wie kann man die lesen.
Ja war schwierig zu entziffern ja.
Aber sag cool aus.
Ja sehr cool aus.
Ich finde das also dieses zugesperrt ist immer man geht ein relativ großes Risiko ein irgendwie was Geldstrafen Haftstrafen oder sonstiges angeht und am Ende gibt's im gesunden,
so Einzug der sieht äußerst schön aus wird aber relativ zügig danach wieder gereinigt ne das ist ja so ein also man könnte.
Man findet weniger Hobbys die für so wenig Wirksamkeit so hohe Risiken eingehen oder oder täusche ich mich da.
Also wir sind wir waren extrem gut organisiert also das ist natürlich auch was ganz ganz spannendes wenn man in die Szene rein rutscht dass es nur die Sprüher kennen sich untereinander also vor allem die die illegal malen gehen,
man hat sein legal sprühen aber man hat dein illegalen Spinner,
ein Mann hat auch in unterschiedlichen Namen sogar für Züge malen und für spawning also so war es bei uns in Stuttgart ihren falls ich da bist immer noch so und.
Der Unterschied zwischen Züge malen und bombing.
Er ist das gefährlicher also die Geldstrafen sind viel viel höher wenn du zügig malst das heißt du hast dann noch mal in anderen kuhnamen in der Regel also du wärst total blöd wenn du die Stadt voll malst mit einem Namen und dann mit dem Zug erwischt wirst und dann plötzlich für alles Erkner.
Das heißt du hast da unterschiedliche Namen deine Blackbox hast du nie zu Hause liegen.
MacBooks in Didim.
Genau die die Bücher in die man sozusagen indem man lügt und seines.
Also für die nahezu die Deko mit dir niemals zu Gitta pusht.
Ja genau und ja aber das also die Züge sind halt deswegen spannend weil die hat also einerseits die Reihe die Reisen halt für dich die tragen deine Kunst,
an Dich ganz Europa im besten Fall also man geht in internationales oder man Mahlzeit S-Bahn und Andi tragen die Kunst sozusagen durch die ganze Stadt,
und man erfreut sich dann morgens im Berufsverkehr fährt der Zug ein und man sitzt da mit seiner Kamera und ist einfach unfassbar.
Und wie viel wie viel ist das so Selbstverwirklichung dass man sich selbst sehen will so ein typischer Ausdruck soll ich sagen von jugendlicher expression und wie viel ist botschaft.
Also Botschafter auf alle Fälle also teils teils also die Botschaft in meistens hat man seinen Style und dann hat man meistens auf eine politische Botschaft die man noch klein daneben malt
aber es ist auf jeden Fall das war damals einfach die Szene also es war dieses Gefühl von von Hip Hop sich mit Kunst zu betteln,
wenn ja dann vom sprühen ziemlich schnell auch dazu gekommen dass ich selber Musik gemacht habe direkt ab,
und dann sozusagen mit dieser Sprache noch mal mehr das was du gerade ansprichst diese politische Botschaft man die noch mal anders verpacken kann dadurch dass man einfach viel viel mehr Text hat und auf der Bühne steht.
Von welchem damals reden wir jetzt gerade so.
90er in den Neunzigern,
und dann war das in Stuttgart also damals war mit massiver Töne groß oder Freundeskreis und das rutschte dann ab den 2000 dann ziemlich schnell in diese kommerzielle Ecke und ich bin auch Anfang 2000 dann nach Berlin.
Also du hast Hip Hop gemacht bevor es cool war.
Genau sagen.
Dann als Schwabe nach Berlin ein.
Wäre das da das da kann ich mich ja auch noch dran erinnern die sind ja ein ähnliches Alter des Stuttgarter irgendwie da da war in der Zeit was na die haben ist also Stuttgart kam einfach viel.
Wart ihr hip hop fans oder was war so eure Musik Sozialisation.
Ich habe Hip Hop nicht,
ganz interessant aber es war nicht meine Sozialisation ich fand diese eckigen Töne die aus meinem Computerspiele rausgegangen weil ich super und dann Techno kam dachte ich mir einen lauf.
Ja das habe ich dann in Berlin kennengelernt.
Ich habe da ich habe glaube ich früher schon so ein bisschen Techno gehört also massiv.
Aber das gab der Gast irgendwie aus Hamburg so,
Dynamite Deluxe und solche dann gabs Stuttgart hast du gerade schon gesagt und dann gabs aber auch Ruhrgebiet Hip Hop viel eigentlich dadurch auch sehr viel.
Einfacher zu sein.
Meine Spezialität.
Ja das war der Fall weil weil das ganze so too strong Ruhrkohle AG oder Ruhrpott AG und solche Sachen das musste man hören wenn man kiffen wollte.
Genau.
Zum ist aber nicht alleine kämpfen wollte musste man sich das anhören.
Was hat dein Berlin mit dir gemacht also was was hast du denn weiter angefangen weiter weiter Züge angemalt oder war das dann irgendwie braucht es diese Kompensation nicht mehr.
Diese Kompensation ich bin ja ich bin nach Berlin gegangen also erstens weil ich Lust hatte auf eine Großstadt,
und Auszug Gardinen wollte aber ich hatte damals in Stuttgart so einen lustigen Nebenjob als brennerin bei einer Fernsehserie bei der Kinder Fernsehserien.
Ja da habe ich weil da ging es um sprain und Kinder die sprain und dann habe ich immer das Z sozusagen wieder auf Anfang.
Und dann habe ich angefangen in dieser Kinderserie eine Rolle zu spielen als Priorin,
und bin dann in der Fernseh Business als Schauspielerin reingerutscht sozusagen und bin dann nach Berlin gegangen auch weil hier irgendwie gedreht wird und,
Anja weil ich dich mega spannend war nur.
Walt Disney Kinderserie übers Freren.
Die LEDs effabrics und die lief auf dem kika richtig schlecht.
Und er würde den Kindern sprühen beigebracht.
Ja also es wurde sozusagen auf jeden Fall die wollte natürlich ganz nah an der Straßenszene sein und sowas und haben dann natürlich auch Kinder gehabt die ist brain und breakdancen und was was da nicht alles war.
Düsseldorf ich erzähl du willst auch mal erwischt ne da war es aber auch noch ein Kind insofern weil in Ordnung.
Genau ich wurde ich war unter 18 ich wurde erwischt in dem Yard in stutt Stuttgart,
wir waren in dem Yard und es war schon so ein ungutes Gefühl das ist eigentlich das was man da nicht machen soll eigentlich soll man nach Hause gehen aber wir lagen irgendwie schon,
3 Stunden im Matsch im Regen und hatten Ausschau gehalten nach dem Bahn werfen und den Zug fahren und wir dachten wir müssen heute raus wenn wir rausgegangen und,
werden mal wir waren schon fertig aber zum Glück alle mit Sturmmaske und alle mit Handschuhen gucke ich nach rechts und sie nicht weit von mir entfernt zwei BGS Beamten im Gras sitzen.
Und ich tippe nur meine Kollegen an und dann und dann sind wir los gerannt und natürlich also das ist auch eine super männliche Stine,
ich war die einzige Frau oder ich konnte nicht so schnell rennen die Jungs haben mich gepackt ich wurde erwischt nach Stuttgart in dieses BGS Gefängnis,
dann alles wie man so kennen SOPO auseinander nach Drogen gucken alles Mögliche zu meinen Eltern nach Hause geschleppt und ich habe meine Eltern dachten im ersten Moment als FIBS Beamten vor der Tür standen geklingelt haben nachts um 12 Uhr,
Gottes Willen das Kind dealt mit Heroin hast mir gesagt,
aber nein ich habe nur gesprüht und dann waren meine Eltern so geistesgegenwärtig.
Kein geübt hast du.
Dann habe ich zu meinen Eltern gesagt so schläft meine Schwester oben in dem Zimmer.
Und dann waren sie so geistesgegenwärtig und haben zum Glück die BGs Beamten zu Hausdurchsuchungen in das Zimmer von meiner Schwester geschickt,
meine Schwester ist zwei Jahre jünger als ich und hat überall so Ballett Poster hängen gehabt bitte Barbies,
und die haben dann alles durch also alles durchsucht so und natürlich nichts gefunden wahrscheinlich hatte ich Unmengen an Gras in meinem Zimmer keine Ahnung jedenfalls hat dass mich gerettet.
Also könntest du weiter auf dem Kieker das den Gospel des Graffiti singen.
Vista nach Berlin gezogen und in Berlin ich finde immer so ein bisschen also mein Mann beobachtet ja also erstmal wie ortet man sich selber färben nach Berlin City mir auch nach Berlin gezogen.
Wann bist du nach Berlin gezogen.
2004.
Ich 2003.
Siehst du und das ist genau das man merkt sofort nicht mehr auch schon länger hier in das ist.
Einfach das ist so typisch an tim ist noch länger hier ist.
Ja guck mal aber du bist auch älter.
Das kommt alles zusammen.
Aber nicht soviel wir sind alle zu spät gegangen das wissen wir auf jeden Fall.
Wo kommt ihr her.
Aus Hannover ist auch nicht so schön.
Glaube ich ja und du.
Die also so die DDD Prototyp das prototypische keine kaputte typische Karriere Verlauf einer Person die nach Berlin zieht ist erstmal so ein bisschen also I so geil dann merkst du wie.
Tanzen die Leute sich so fast an den Abgrund und entweder bleiben sie dann genau da jahrelang.
Jahrzehnte.
Oder sich sie finden dann auch häufig stelle ich so fest mach man dann so nach 2-3 vielleicht vier Jahren doch eh wieder mal so eine ganz.
Radikale Änderungen oder so der Sinne Wände wo man erwidern auf Mac okay kassiert hat die Person sich irgendwie gefunden ne aber sieht man muss einmal so mit diesen überwältigenden Möglichkeiten irgendwie umgehen und Märklin wieso dass sie,
also ich ich stell das einfach bei vielen Leuten Festina nach Berlin ziehen und erstmal viel ausprobieren kurz vielleicht so eine Phase der Orientierungslosigkeit haben hier war auch total geil ist.
Also meine Phase der Orientierungslosigkeit kam erst später weil als ich nach Berlin gekommen bin da war für mich klar ich will eigentlich Schauspiel noch mal richtig leer,
ich habe dann bei einem privaten Schauspielschule hier angefangen habe dem her gedreht so es war ziemlich safeman ist dann einfach drinnen und musste Tafi arbeiten und er liebt seinen Beruf und,
und dann bin ich nach dieser Schauspielausbildung bin ich tatsächlich am nach Innsbruck gegangen weil ich dachte ich will am Theater Schauspielerin werden.
Und er hatte dan Engagement in Innsbruck am Theater und das war schrecklich es war alles andere als,
was ich jemals wollte also ich war schon immer eigentlich extreme politischer Mensch ich habe immer so nach einem nach einem Ventil gesucht um mit Kunstpolitik zu machen irgendwie,
und dachte eigentlich dass ich das als Schauspielerin aufmachen kann tolle Stücke spielen kann und dann kommst du an so ein peppiges Ensemble nach Innsbruck ins war die absolute Hölle,
und meine meine Zeit der Orientierungslosigkeit hat dann eigentlich angefangen als ich von Innsbruck wieder zurück nach Berlin kam weil man dann irgendwie denkt okay,
was will ich denn jetzt also wenn ich es irgendwie nicht,
Schlingensief war dann schon nicht mehr ja also mit dem konnte ich kein Theater mehr machen das heißt was für eine Art Theater will ich eigentlich machen was für eine Schauspielerin will ich sein und dann hast du halt dieses ganze Ding so,
ja Party machen Kellnern kochen diese ganzen Dinge die man so in Berlin macht und so guckt was will ich eigentlich machen wie kann ich mich aus.
Christoph Schlingensief wäre schon deinen Fall gewesen.
Auf jeden Fall also ich war absoluter Fan ich habe es einfach unglaublich geliebt dass jemand reinkommt und sozusagen leck mich Theater ruft eigentlich,
und trotzdem einen großen Häusern spielt und einfach einen riesen Ramba Zamba macht unglaublich geil.
Ja doch extrem politischen seiner seiner seiner Kunst war.
Ja ich weiß nicht in dem Sinne wie wir es jetzt z.b. machen würde ich jetzt nicht so in dem Sinne politisch aber für mich war er ein großer Künstler ja ein eine einen einer.
Schick uns wenn man irgendwie die Arbeitslosen des Landes zusammen ruft um irgendwie über den See zu schwimmen zum Kanzler Urlaubsort,
und damals hat mich auch dieses Chancen 2000 Projekt also scheitern als Chance man damit gemeint in Berlin sowieso schon mal ganz gut,
klarkommen mit dem Motto so aber da da da ist Krieg gleich zusammen also ich finde es das in viel Hoffnung drin,
und die ganze Art und Weise wie er auch Leute zusammengebracht hat seine ausbauen das gemacht hat mit Behinderten.
Ja einfach einfach die Grenzen gesprengt und das fand ich das aller spannend sein ihn einfach Grenzen zu sprengen,
nicht in eine Schublade sich packen zu lassen sondern einfach Nazis mit Behinderten auf die Bühne zu bringen die Bühne einfach vors Theater zu bringen die Bühne woanders hin zu bringen natürlich noch vorm Internet aber,
diese Bühne woanders stattfinden zulassen einfach der Hammer.
Was hat das denn für dich ausgelöst also wie konntest du dann dein Wunsch zum politischen Ausdruck gerecht werden.
Die lachen die lachen die die lachen immer weil der Roller so lustige Sachen da hinten mahlt aber wir wir gucken da gar nicht hin.
Man schon manchmal ne aber das Lenken.
Ab und zu ja ich habe dann ich habe dann angefangen weil ich das Gefühl hatte als Schauspielerin wirst Du gebucht.
Und du kannst aber nicht selber Geschichten erzählen wie es vorher eigentlich als Rapperin selber Geschichten erzählt habe,
also habe ich einfach mal angefangen selber Filme zu machen und ich hatte dann das große Glück eine gute Freundin von mir war befreundet mit Philipp.
Und oder ist immer noch sehr gut befreundet mit Philipp Ruch einer gesagt die Erde macht so verrückte Sachen die musste mal unbedingt kennenlernen und.
Sag mir auch irgendwann mal jemand gesagt.
Und dann dachte ich immer noch so naja so ein Student,
so ja ich weiß nicht das war nicht so nicht so meine Szene so am Anfang als ich ihn kennengelernt habe und wir haben dann zusammen aber einen Film gemacht über nahrungsmittelspekulationen.
Und so habe ich Philipp kennengelernt so habe ich Andrea kennengelernt vom Zentrum und bin dann da Stück für Stück eingestiegen.
Genau.
Und das alles andere stehen und liegen lassen.
Nee nee das konnte ich damals noch nicht aber ja das war so ein so ein so ein schleichender Prozess immer mehr mit dem Zentrum gemeinsam zu machen genau.
Und jetzt kommen wir quasi von dieser Situation wo du.
Mit meiner kurzen Jahreszahl wo sind wir jetzt.
2010.
Jetzt bist du quasi abgerutscht von noch minderjährig beim Sprühen erwischt und deine Eltern helfen dir,
als als Komplizen noch aus der Nummer raus und jetzt bist du in einer in einer kriminellen Vereinigung,
die hier auch ihre Komplizen an Ort und Stelle hatte ich sehe die ein oder anderen Politiker view T-Shirt schon im im Publikum hier in der ersten Reihe.
Sehr cool.
Würdest du jetzt im Nachhinein als als geradlinigen Weg gesehen oder würdest du das also wie ihm.
Kommen da jetzt die Sachen zusammen was was ist es bist du jetzt von der Schauspielerin zur Theater Macherin gewandelt oder was genau macht überhaupt der Planungsstab im ZDF.
Ja okay also erstmal geradliniger weg also wenn ich jetzt hier mit euch sitze und wir jetzt so sagen ja ich war damals kriminell heute bin ich immer noch dann ist es auf jeden Fall ein sehr geradliniger weg.
Nee also ich glaube das ist ja das ist ja sogar das ist totale spannende eigentlich dass mir selber kommt ist natürlich überhaupt nicht als der geradlinige Weg Form,
und das ist auch,
habe ich einen Punkt der total wichtig ist für alle die wo wir uns und geradlinig fühlen auf unseren Wegen dass man immer wieder vielleicht diese also diese Momente wo wir jetzt hier sitzen werden wahrscheinlich,
wenigsten haben aber dass man irgendwie noch mal zurück schaut und die,
Perlen auf eine Kette zusammenbringt und dann doch merkt dass das irgendwie was miteinander zu tun hat und dass man sich eine gewisse expertiz auf ganz vielen verschiedenen Gebieten dann doch aneignet und dass man weiß wo geht's hinten also es geht ja letztlich darum.
Seine PS die man in sich hat irgendwie zu versuchen auf eine Straße zu bringen damit man damit das machen kann,
wofür man brennt an was seine Leidenschaft ist und ich glaube wenn du mich danach fragst dann hat es irgendwie ganz gut gibt's für jeden Moment den richtigen,
und das hat ganz gut funktioniert also ich muss sagen ich habe mit dem,
Zentrum für politische Schönheit absolut meine künstlerische Heimat gefunden weil sie so wunderschön unverschämt ist,
weil ich die Kunst verbinden kann mit dem Willen läuten politisch richtig auf den Sack zu gehen und dabei,
ja irgendwie daran zu rütteln dass es wirklich schlimm ist dass wir in Europa sitzen und dass Menschen im Mittelmeer sterben und dass wir uns damit immer wieder auseinander.
Das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen also was ich bei den Centrums Aktion dich ja allesamt für besonders genial orchestriert halte immer wieder sehe das.
Im weitesten Sinne Geschmacklosigkeit mit einer Geschmacklosigkeit begegnet wird,
also die meisten Zentrums Aktionen werden dann irgendwie moralisch kritisiert na das kann man aber nicht machen.
Ihr stellt euch aber im Prinzip hin und sagt ja aber also das hier finden wir aber auch irgendwie nicht in Ordnung ne die.
Wie fahre ich tatsächlich von den Centrums Aktionen manchmal Wie kommt.
Also man merkt ja im weiteren Verlauf merkt man da steckt auf jeden das wird nicht das passiert ja nicht gerade zufällig oder das wurde jetzt nicht mal das keinen Schnellschuss der da irgendwie.
Ja es ist ganz unterschiedlich wir sagen wir haben mittlerweile die luxuriöse Positionen ich habe immer das Gefühl also im im Haupt künstlerischen Team mit Stefan und andre und mir und Philipp,
ist sodass wir sowieso eine gealterte Band sind die sich alle tierisch teilweise auf den Sack gehen aber unglaublich gut zusammenarbeiten können mittlerweile über die Jahre,
also wir haben so ein gutes Blatt der eine kann ohne den anderen nicht und so so gehen wir alle zu Fürth,
eigentlich immer an die Aktion dran wenn wir die machen die Ideen sind entweder liegen die auf dem Tisch dann sagt einer eine Idee,
das hat mir schon und alle sagen ist der absolute Hammer genau das müssen wir machen es war z.b.
Bei die Toten kommen so am da wusste man einfach diese Idee zündet und dann recherchiert man und dann arbeitet man und arbeitet monatelang um zu gucken ist das möglich ist das möglich jemanden der schon beerdigt,
quer durch Europa transportieren zu können wie können wir es machen in der Zusammenarbeit,
mimpara damals ja waren Paare aus Berlin der nach dem Mauerfall nach der Mauerfall Aktion gesagt hatte ihr müsst unbedingt mal was gegen die Kirche machen hatte er gesagt,
und und.
Der Mann wusste wovon er redet.
Absolut und der war dann einfach so geil am auch in diesem Moment das hat dann auch alles zusammen auch die Möglichkeit uns zu geben den Imam zu finden die,
die Friedhöfe zu finden gegen die auch sich alle noch gesträubt hatten intern am dass da tatsächlich die Beerdigung statt,
am genau und manche Ideen bei manchen Ideen dass es so dass man eine Idee hat und dann recherchiert man manchmal auch ins Leere und das kann auch sein dass man länger mal entleere recherchiert,
und man guckt einfach ist da genug Stoff da und dass es,
dass das erzählen kann oder das trägt auf allen möglichen ähneln wie wir es dann auch erzählen wollen.
Versteht ihr euch eigentlich mehr als Künstler oder als Aktivisten oder ist es eine Mischung aus beidem.
Wir machen politische Kunst und das heißt wir sind auf jeden Fall in dem Sinne,
politische Aktivisten aber auf jeden Fall mit künstlerischen Mitteln also ich finde,
das sieht man ganz gut an der Aktion auch erster europäischer Mauerfall,
wenn wir gewollt hätten also rein aktivistisch gewollt hätten dass es nur darum geht dass die europäische Grenze fällt oder dass wir da ein Loch rein kriegen,
dann hätten wir es viel schlauer organisierten die wäre einfach.
Still und heimlich runtergefahren werden keiner hetzt mitbekommen werden die Grenze aufgemacht an das wäre dann aufjedenfall aktivistisch gewesen aber.
Verse DDD Herangehensweise vom yard sprühen gewesen.
Auf jeden Fall du willst genau keiner genau auf jeden Fall aber was für mich,
das zu Kunstmarkt oder das in die anderen Ebenen auch bringt also die Geschichte dir doch auch erzählt werden muss,
es eben dieser Größe und Bogen den wir versuchen bei jeder Aktion zu erzählen das heißt wir wollen,
erzählen in dem spezifischen Fall wollten wir erzählen Leute ihr feiert gerade mit Millionen an Steuergeldern das eine innerdeutsche Grenze gefallen ist ja in der Menschen gestorben sind,
und gleichzeitig bauen wir gerade mit Millionen an Steuergeldern neu Grenzen auch bei den neue Menschen sterben und befragt.
Und an diese Geschichte zu erzählen und diese Geschichte auch so zu spannen dass man sagt es gibt Menschen es war auch die erste Aktion die wir gemacht haben wo wir,
dazu aufgerufen haben dass Leute im Busse steigen mit uns partizipativ mit runterfahren,
dass man das erzählt und dass das dann auch bekannt geworden ist als es war ja so dass wir losgefahren sind von Gorki Theater mit zwei Bussen damals die wir gekaut fandet hatten.
Die Berliner Polizei das wussten wir damals nicht hatte dann aber schon an das Bundeskriminalamt gefunkt und an alle Grenzländer drum herum und gesagt bekommen zwei Busse mit Paula verrückten die wollen die EU-Außengrenze niederreißen,
und damit damit war dann eigentlich unser Projekt in dem Sinne weil wir sind vorher runtergefahren wir sind echt runtergefahren mehrfach und haben geguckt,
wo ist es am kältesten wo kann der Kempten,
wo ist das ruhig wo können wir irgendwie mit den zwei Bussen ankommen und dann schön unserem Bolzenschneider in Löcher reinschneiden und ich war da nicht mehr möglich weil wir wurden an jeder Grenze komplett auseinandergenommen alle Personalien von den Leuten wurden,
aufgenommen es war der nicht mehr möglich also wenn du fragst Aktivist,
genau wie du es beschrieben hast macht man still und heimlich oder am Arbeiten arbeitet man auch mit der Presse und ich glaube da arbeiten wir auch,
ganz so wie wie die Greenpeace am Anfang gearbeitet hat also sehr viel mit Presse am zusammenzuarbeiten sofort ein Thema was wir finden über was nicht mehr gesprochen wird das wirklich in die Medien wieder zu,
auf die Titelblätter.
Und damit natürlich auch eine gesellschaftliche Debatte auszulösen IMI.
Luzern.
Und habt ihr den Eindruck dass euch das gelingt.
Ich denke schon also dass uns das gelingt dass die Familien am Küchentisch wieder debattieren ob es okay ist jetzt dem höckelmann mal in deinen Nachbargarten zu,
einbauen oder nicht kräftig mit einfach.
Und da steht übrigens immer noch.
Jedenfalls bleibt mindestens die nächsten zehn Jahre ich glaube Film kann es aber noch länger finanz.
Mindestens die nächsten 10 Jahre.
Ja auf jeden Fall genau also die Kosten wurden damit Gedeck.
Der Mietvertrag hält auch noch so lange.
Bis jetzt haben wir alle Gerichtsverhandlung darüber gewonnen und der Vermieter muss sich beugen
wer muss also zu sagen ja er ist Museumswärter eines Mahnmals.
Wird schon mal noch mal dieses woran misst man seinen Erfolg ja also ich meine klar Öffentlichkeit das gelingt euch eine Debatte wird auch geführt aber man merkt natürlich auch sofort,
manche stolpern über euch und machen dann Fehler und das ist ein gewisser Hinsicht also in der in der Debatte und in entlaufen sich selber das natürlich dann eine ein weiterer
inzwischen erfolgreich ich mal langfristig möchte man ja natürlich dass es sich ändert.
Klar man sollte sich sicherlich nicht überschätzen und glauben man könnte jetzt mit einer beliebigen Aktion gleich das Rad der Geschichte in die andere Richtung schwingen lassen aber ihr werdet doch vielleicht zumindest auch,
oder vielleicht frei auch mal dich persönlich weißt du du bist ja selber eine Erwartung haben wie weit ihr ist denn vielleicht treiben können wie weiter
Kraft hier Wirkung zeigt um Dinge auch tatsächlich.
Zumindest zu entschleunigen oder wenn ich sogar in eine andere Richtung zu bewegen bist du dann sozusagen zufrieden mit dem wie es ist darf man Dani,
zufrieden sein oder darf man sich davon gar nicht abhalten lassen also wie Gewicht ist du selber verdichten.
Also,
ich bin selten zufrieden es ist auch interessant dass jeder von uns auch im Zentrum ein anderes im Verhältnis zu diesem was ist Erfolg ist dann am Ende von der Aktion ich muss sagen ganz persönlich manchmal ist es
sind das also.
Manchmal das große dass man das Gefühl hat z.b. gerade mit dem höcke Mahnmal denke ich es war es wahnsinnig wichtig die AFD zieht in den Bundestag ein mit über 12 % und man merkt so,
es ist eine absolute Lähmung die in diesem Land stattfindet und man
das Gefühl ich weiß noch in Berlin damals haben viele ja auch diese Wahlveranstaltung von der AFD noch gestürmt und man hat das Gefühl ich muss jetzt auf die Straße gehen aber man wusste nicht richtig in welche Richtung geht das und für mich war es dann einfach ein wahnsinniger Volk in dem
Moment wo wir das gemacht haben dass man das Gefühl hatte man hat so ein,
in Stein gemeißeltes oder im Theater Beton gemeißelt das Zeichen gesetzt und dann habe ich mit der israelischen Presse ich hatte ein Live Interview,
am mit dem israelischen Radiosender und der Radiomoderator hat sich gar nicht mehr eingekriegt vor Lachen,
darüber was wir da gemacht haben und das sind so Momente die für mich totaler Erfolg bedeuten womes geführt,
noch mal so eine andere Ebene erreicht dass man ein Zeichen gesetzt hat dass es hier so viele Menschen gibt in Deutschland die sich wirklich aktiv und laut,
gegen Rechts äußern möchten ja oder sind wirklich manchmal ganz kleine Sachen einfach mit den Familien mit denen man in Kontakt tritt mit den Aktionen die ehrlich gesagt für mich dann Erfolg ausmachen.
Jetzt hat gerade die höcke Aktion natürlich auch dies kuriert,
und die und wie auch die komplette Bandbreite an Reaktionen gerufene also unvergessen der Anruf der AFD Einhorn Standarte die zur spontanen Gründung der logbuch-netzpolitik Einhorn Standarte für.
Totenkopfstandarte ja.
Ich ich Geld kann dir das ist so ein Spinner ich weiß genau wovon der darauf geredet hat aber die AFD totenkopfstandarte holt ruft an,
wir gründen sofort wurde die Aldi logbuch-netzpolitik Einhorn Standarte aber es gab ja auch wirklich Schlägereien oder Angriffe auf euch vor diesem Haus ist gab konkrete Drohung gegen,
Mitglieder des zps es gab jetzt diese diese da sind wieder Roland ne,
oder lachen über mich nee okay.
Die würde niemals würde ich lachen Dino.
Anime.
So gut sind deine Witze.
FCZ.
Dann bin ich beruhigt.
Also ihr habt ihr wart konkret konkreten Drogen ausgesetzt und ihr konntet vielleicht viel kalkulieren in dieser höcke Aktion aber irgendwie soll ich mal das Gewaltpotential und der Hass in ihr da auch auf euch zieht.
Das ist ja nicht unbedingt nicht wirklich kalkulierbar das ist irgendwie kein kein Risiko was eingeplant werden kann.
Ja so so also ich glaube wir sind uns schon vor allem nach der höcke Aktion sind wir genauso wie beim Graffiti ja wir ziehen uns im im übertragenen Sinne unsere
Handschuhe an damit man nicht unsere Fingerabdrücke findet und wir haben unsere Sturmmasken auf und wir lassen keine Spuren im Netz wir sind da auf jeden Fall ja,
wir wissen mit wem wir es da zu tun haben auf der Gegenseite auf jeden Fall ist.
Kaisers.
Genau OpSec,
das auf jeden Fall ja ja also natürlich was man natürlich nicht weiß ist,
die im Untergrund lebenden gewaltbereiten Nationalsozialist also Nazis hat man keine Ahnung was die mit einem Vorhaben auf jeden Fall ja.
Wie wirkt sich das denn so auf dein Privatleben aus meine schränkt dich das ein ist das ein Preis den du,
bereit bist zu zahlen wo es da für dich die Grenze im viele trauen sich ja auch in solche aktivistischen Bereiche nicht rein weil sie halt
in irgendeiner Form Schaden für sich oder andere befürchten das ist ja auch etwas wo man den Mut erstmal für auf.
Ja also ich glaube in unserem Fall jetzt und es ist mir auch super wichtig das zu sagen also wir leben halt immer noch in Deutschland,
mit allem was vielleicht auch nicht so gut läuft im Gegensatz zu Russland oder der Türkei Leute absolut wir brauchen hier mehr Widerständler ja wir sind,
wir sind eigentlich in dem Land wo wir sehr sehr gut geschützt sind vor allem wenn man es nicht ganz blöd anstellt,
auch wenn man jetzt Radikalreaktion plant dann,
sucht euch aufjedenfall Anwälte oder zumindestens Leute die Jura studieren die erkennt am tut euch mit denen von Anfang an zusammen schützt euch bei euren Aktionen und geht nicht blauäugig vor aber ansonsten muss man in dem Falle,
jetzt erstmal würde ich sagen keine Angst am also ich habe keine Angst in meinem,
an das schränkt mich nicht ein Mann muss sagen wann fängt manchmal ein bisschen,
wir haben wenn man jemanden neu kennenlernt dann denkt man,
muss man ab und zu mal genauer nachfragen was die Person so macht und wo die herkommt und so in dem Fall ja aber ansonsten nicht.
Also ich glaube das ist das ist auf jeden Fall was extrem wichtiges ja wir haben alle viel viel viel zu viel an,
schon bei den kleinsten Sachen also die Grenzen zu übertreten oder es fängt ja schon dabei an dass Leute sich nicht trauen in der großen Runde wenn jemand anfängt dumme ein,
Sprüche oder rechtsradikale Sprüche ich meinen Töchtern lieben wir auch alle eine absoluten Blase und das findet er nicht statt aber,
ich würde mal sagen die Mehrheit der Menschen liebt ihm nicht in dieser Blase und trifft immer wieder auf die,
und auch schon da dann an das Wort zu ergreifen und auch Bestellung zu beziehen für schwächere oder andere da fängt es ja schon an dass die Leute sich nicht,
ich habe Leute kennengelernt die auf Lehramt studieren und sie sich nicht trauen auf eine Demo zu gehen und Plakat hochzuhalten weil sie Angst haben dass sie dann nicht verbeamtet,
also das halte ich für gefährlich wenn diese Angst uns lähmt.
Vor allem zu lange solange sie noch unbegründet ist ne.
Was würdest du in Raten die die Leuten raten die diese Angst haben also man kann das ja als eine irrationale ungerechtfertigte angstempfinden aber wenn sie nun mal da ist durch Prägung etc was könnte ein Weg sein das von innen heraus zu überwinden.
Na ja ich muss gerade ein so so irrationale Ängste wie Flugzeug Angst vor Fliegen oder so denken dass es total schwierig den was zu raten aber ich sagen nimm eine valium und Trinken Wodka und steig einfach ins Flugzeug bei politischem Aktivismus,
es ist schwieriger vielleicht auch valium und Wodka hilft bestimmt auch.
Vielleicht nicht gleichzeitig.
Vielleicht nicht gleichzeitig weiß nicht aber ansonsten.
Ich denke das total wichtig ist sich darüber im Klaren zu werden was haben wir zu verlieren,
weil ich denke dass wir in der Zeit leben wir haben keinen Krieg erlebt wir sind uns in der Regel gar nicht bewusst darüber was für ein Geschenk ist ist in dieser Demokratie zu leben,
und was für ein Geschenk ist es wählen zu gehen was für ein Geschenk ist ist auf die Straße gehen zu können was bewegen zu können Dinge anzuzetteln und ich denke schon dass dieses Bewusstsein darüber,
vielleicht hilft dass Menschen sich mehr trauen auch dafür einzustehen,
und sie,
dass wir ganz viel mit dem Zentrum auch am Workshops machen bei den absurdesten Organisationen also wer waren zwei Spiele bei Verdi mal und Verdi beigebracht wie man politisch aktiver,
Dinge machen kann so sehr lustig.
Er mich auch echt keine Ahnung.
Nirali keine Ahnung von haben sie keinen blassen Schimmer von,
oder am Kirchenvertreter die auch wieder also die Kirche sehr interessant also wahrscheinlich die ganze flüchtlingsdiskussion in Deutschland da ist die Kirche doch dann so merkt man immer wieder,
sehr vereinzelt doch so am haben die Lust an radikalen neuen Form also wir hatten schon öfters mit der Kirche zu tun haben die gebrieft sowie können die radikaler werden.
Mit mit welcher von den beiden.
Evangelisch immer immer evangelisch am wobei ich wir hatten zweimal schon einmal bei der CDU Sache wir haben ja damals,
ich habe letzten Sommer haben wir die CSU Zentrale in Bayern umbenannt in die CDU Zentrale und da war auch ein Priester dabei uns gibt einen sehr aktiven Priester katholischen Priester,
der auch sehr radikale ist weil er natürlich sagt das ist sehr spannend die Kirche war immer schon radikal ja da gab es schon immer ja Menschen die,
durch die Straße von Menschlichkeit die ersten Aktionskünstler sozusagen damals waren also da da steckt schon viel drin in der Kirche eigentlich.
Wie ist das denn ich.
Ihr führt jetzt die Kirche wieder zum waren weg.
Jajaja.
Also ich stelle ich stelle manchmal fest dass.
Dass man vielleicht eigentlich politischen Aktivismus betreibt um andere Menschen zu ermutigen und irgendwie.
Vorbildfunktion oder irgendwas los zustoßen irgendwie zu ermöglichen mit dem Club und also mit dem Chaos Computer Club machen wir auch die ein oder andere politische Aktion.
Wir hatten auch mal das ein oder andere System,
und ich stelle häufig fest dass dann Menschen wirklich auf uns zukommen sage hier ihr müsstet mal das und das da hacken ne also wirklich so die wo man sie denkt sie nee nee so war das eigentlich nicht gedacht passiert das bei euch auch.
Ja ich glaube also wir kriegen ich glaube mindestens drei Nachrichten pro Tag über Facebook Messenger wo es Leute Aktionen Vorschlägen erschlagen was wir denn alles machen könnten,
also das passiert und der oft oder auch nach den Aktion dass sie sagen naja es wär ja schön und gut dass ihr das Mahnmal da und dahin gebaut hat aber habt ihr euch nicht mal überlegt dass man mal da und da einzubauen das passiert uns sehr häufig und,
das ist ja auch eine sehr spannende Sache ja Ideen haben halt viele,
auch sehr geile Ideen auf jeden Fall auch sehr krasse Ideen aber diese Ideen dann auch wirklich durchzuziehen das ist ja das worauf es ankommt und was.
Für uns glaube ich auch so ein Lernprozess war über die Jahre zu merken also oder auch für alle die bei uns angefangen haben zu arbeiten zu merken dass,
irgendeine Mutter hat mal über uns gesagt ihr habt ja gar keinen Künstlerleben ihr steht ja morgens früh auf und geht ins büro also diese Diskrepanz zwischen,
diese Diskrepanz zwischen.
Nein ich will was verändern oder diese Energien die ich auch schon immer geliebt habe so am 1. Mai im schwarzen Block und es ist so geil und du willst was machen willst was wegen und dann aber wirklich was geiles auf die Beine stellen weil das bedeutet dann oft einfach,
monatelang wirklich stupide ganz detaillierte,
dumme Arbeit ja also immer wieder beim beim Amt für lölölö anrufen,
fährt denn da das machen können und wie das ist und die Gesetzestexte abchecken und so weiter und so fort,
genau also das ist glaube ich weiß was das sehr wichtiges ist wenn man versucht aktiv zu werden also die Diskrepanz zwischen der Energie der Idee,
der Ausführung.
Also es gibt Durststrecken.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das sind also das erinnert mich auch wieder ich versuche Parallelen zu ziehen und an das Haken,
ja weil das auch immer so man stellt sich das immer so vor dass man da immer am Computer sitzt und paar Sachen runter hacked und dann da da in Wirklichkeit ist braucht man dafür glaube ich einfach eine enorme Frustrationstoleranz,
und das ist eigentlich das was ich weil natürlich am Ende findet man 20 Schwachstellen man hat aber nach 2000 gesucht und diese,
immer wieder zu sehen aber okay hier geht's nicht weiter ich probiere es mal so ich konstruiere mir das und da dran zu bleiben das ist eigentlich das was ich irgendwie.
Feststelle bei denen so den besten hacken die ich irgendwie kenne das hier,
diese durch Durststrecken gehen mit durch mitten mit Frustrationstoleranz dasitzen anstellen wohl wo ich dann irgendwann auch wirklich dann so Sachen schaltcomputer ich will was anderes machen mit Blumen oder Holz oder so und dann,
dann hast du aber.
Man kann ja man dann auch mal einen Tag was mit blumenholz wieder machen wenn man wieder zurückgeht.
Aber dann habe ich ihr habe ich halt irgendwie Kumpels neben mir sitzt die hat sagen so ja nee da müssen wir jetzt dann bleiben ich ich bin nur heute ein bisschen langsam weil ich Migräne habe und Wechsel warst du sitzt da mit Migräne und und sie sitzt hier ist diese Software und.
Ja so wir sitzen im Zentrum immer mit Migräne Daten auf jeden Fall.
Aber so diese diese Frustrationstoleranz und diese diese Sachen halt durchzuhalten nicht irgendwie beim ersten bei der ersten Kleinigkeit sich auch auf die auf die Bus zu prügeln sondern,
Sachen durchzuziehen deswegen finde ich deine deine Position beim ZDF Wer ist ja Planungsstab das heißt du bist da wirklich.
Wir machten Jahresplan oder wie stelle ich mir das vor.
Ja also ich wollte noch mal was zur Frustrationstoleranz eigentlich sagen es ist gerade gesagt hat,
aber ich glaube ich habe den Faden verloren aber ich komme darauf vielleicht nachher noch mal zurück ja also Planungsstab ich glaube ich würde mich ihr Chefin des,
Chaos Organisierens oder so ne also diese Namen haben wir uns ja gegeben also wir haben den Eskalation Spa Auftrag,
dann haben wir den Geheimrat dann Philipp ist Chefunterhändler und ich bin Chefin des Planungsstab.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob dieser Name so sehr auf mich passt also.
Das ist was ich mache also in der jetzt weiß ich jetzt weiß ich wieder was ich sagen,
nee ich glaube das dieses.
Warum man immer weiter durch hält das zu machen was man eigentlich macht,
sm und Essenz unterscheidet es auch sehr warum ich glaube ich nicht mehr am Innsbrucker Theater sein wollte oder so ist schon,
das warum machst du das und wofür machst du das und natürlich wie du auch gesagt hast ja man wird wahrscheinlich nicht die Welt verändern mit einer Aktion aber,
dass man politische Kunst macht weil man glaubt das dass man das was man tut dass es nur ein Stückchen
irgendwas verändern kann oder irgendwie eine Sicht auf auf diese Welt verändern kann oder irgendwie Menschen wieder zum anderen Denken anregen kann weil das
fassbare Ungerechtigkeit passiert dass es eigentlich das was ein zum Durchhalten bringt immer wieder,
und ich glaube das ist schon der groß ist Alleinstellungsmerkmal und deswegen bin ich sehr dankbar dass ich das machen kann was ich machen kann weil ich glaube das könnte ich jetzt nicht in irgendeiner,
Firma für irgendwas ne also dieses durchhalten das macht man schon weil man glaubt dass man die Mission hat.
Thema muss ich auch darüber im Klaren sein dass wenn man so eine Arbeit macht das Erfolge auch nicht unbedingt in Wochen und Monaten gemessen werden kann was vieles davon natürlich auch ne,
langfristige Wirkung hat die man so direkt aber erstmal nicht spürt ich mal wir sitzen hier in reden über Klick Christoph Schlingensief was er mal vor 10-15 Jahren alles angestoßen hat was jetzt wiederum auch Vorbild für andere ist,
ich denke dass das was ihr beim zps macht auf jeden Fall auch diese Qualität hat so und auch langfristig noch wirken wird auch wenn man jetzt die unmittelbaren Schockwellen so meint nicht mehr zu spüren.
Das mal so als Kompliment nebenbei.
Danke schön das nehme ich gerne an.
Und wie heißt es so schön wir können jetzt mal stundenlang quatschen.
Tatsächlich.
Könnten wir auch.
Also ich danke dir sehr.
Ist jetzt schon vorbei.
Ich glaube ja weil wir wir haben wir sind glaube ich schon über die Zeit als.
Ja ja ja ja wir sind schon über alle.
Aber das ist das ist doch so ist das immer wir hatten bei den Live-Sendung davor hatten wir ja vier Leute und dann mussten wir den 20 minuten durchprügeln und jetzt haben wir gesagt 45 Minuten werden ja wohl reichen.
Und das ist glaube ich wieder ein Fehler und eine eine Grenze des live Podcast aber.
Also vielleicht kann ich noch einmal was abschließen oder hast du noch eine Frage also was,
was ich zusätzlich das geile finde an unsere Arbeit dass ich künstlerisch arbeiten darf aber was uns ausmacht ist und anders könnten wir gar nicht arbeiten ist einerseits sich die ganzen Leute die,
und bei jeder Aktion halt ehrenamtlich unterstützen oder die ganzen Leute die die ganze Zeit im Netz,
und mitdiskutieren und ehrenamtlich unterstützen absolut unsere Komplizen weil das was wir machen das wäre einfach nicht machbar ohne die Leute da draußen also,
riesen Respekt an diese Menschen und ja wir machen einfach diese diese wir könnten uns überhaupt nicht finanzieren ohne die Leute die da sind ja und es ist so
fängt an von jemanden der bereit ist unten stand aufzubauen oder sein Auto zu leihen also das wollte ich noch mal sagen wenn ich jetzt schonmal im Netz,
meldet euch bei uns als Komplizen oder als am Bereitschaft Humanist.
Das wollte ich eigentlich ich wollte eigentlich gerade dafür aufrufen,
ich war ja vor ein paar Tagen im Zentrum für politische Schönheit zu Besuch und habe ich mir diese schönen Komplizenschaft Formulare geben lassen die wir draußen liegen H.
Ayaya.
An dem an dem T-Shirt stand und da könnt ihr ja Komplizen werden ihr habt ihr schon die schönen T-Shirts gesehen die man da bekommt nicht schwarz auf schwarz gedruckt da gibt's also noch mal Abzüge im Gegensatz zu den Logbuch netzwelt.
Wir werden neue machen ich habe sowas unser unser Grafiker hat mir etwas ganz Neues gegeben es gibt jetzt T-Shirts wenn man in die Sonne geht dann wird es erst.
Sich in Deutschland selten.
Ja aber auf den ganzen Festivals aber mit dem mit der mit dem Klima.
Eine Hacker community kannst das nicht machen die gehen alle im Keller und sehe nichts.
Ja danke schön.
Happy vielen vielen Dank für das Dabeisein und mitdiskutieren.
Danke schön danke schön.
So Leute Pause ist vorbei weiter geht's.
Ja also auf unsere nimmermüden Suche nach den richtigen Gästen dachten wir uns neben dem,
politischen Aktivismus den wir jetzt schon ein wenig beleuchtet haben schauen wir mal uns mal anders gefärbte Variante,
und blicken auch ein wenig in die Vergangenheit der deutschen Netz Zähne und man das vielleicht so nennen kann dass wir gleich herausfinden,
denn jetzt sprechen wir mit Klaus Landefeld klaus,
komm doch bitte zu uns auf die Bühne.
Bist noch wach Linus.
Ich bin noch wach ja.
Das ist schön wieder wach.
Gestern war ich auch.
Blechtafel.
So jetzt könnte dein Mikrofon auch schon an sein das Kabel ist noch etwas und strategisch über und kannst du mal das Mikro richtig ausrichten das wäre sehr schön.
Station gut verstehe ich das mit den Bechern.
Das jetzt richtig ausgerichtet im Display ne der Kleine ist blechern.
Im Vergleich zu früher mit dem wort nee quatsch.
Bisschen näher noch oder ist das richtig weil der Peter pegadas aus der kämpft dagegen an.
Günstigstes müsste so ein bisschen mehr.
Das anderswo liegen.
Nee nee das alles ruhig mach das mal kurz.
Okay jetzt ist meins aus halts da an.
So hallo Klaus schön dass du es geschafft hast du warst auch sehr schnell mit deiner Antwort als wir dich recht kurzfristig noch angefragt hatten das fand ich super.
Hast du überhaupt Podcast.
Selten habe ich keine Zeit für eigentlich nur noch ersetzen.
Ja ja macht nichts jetzt bisher mittendrin jetzt müssen.
Wenigstens diesen Podcast kannst du jetzt mal hören.
Jetzt müssen wir dich mal ein bisschen einführen also manche,
kenn dich vielleicht auch schon sehr lange andere vielleicht nicht so sehr du agierst auch teilweise mehr im Hintergrund würde ich sagen teilweise auch sehr im Vordergrund,
so oder so gehörst du zu den ersten die in Deutschland so diebitz durch die Leitung gejagt haben das kann man schon so festhalten oder.
Im Internetbereich schon ja andere Netze Garbsen und ich vorher aber ich bin selbst seit 1980 in Netzen unterwegs,
selbst zusammen würden Modems damals.
Ich kann so alt Computer muss man sich aus dem Container ziehen und das war das nicht finanzierbar als Schüler aber Gott sei Dank gab es bei mir in Dreieich wo ich herkomme und das gleich,
Ausblick zu haben sozusagen also bei Frankfurt,
zwei Fünftel Equipment und findet die haben freundlicherweise Containeranlagen damals noch offen heute macht man dann meistens so eine vor oder sowas und da konnte man sich ein bisschen helfen und.
Echt du hast die Computer containerd.
Die haben muss ich dann reparieren übermessen kaputt aber das.
Okay das hast dann auch gleich gemacht mit 12.
Bitte nichts anderes übrig sonst gabs da keine.
Okay,
ja also ich kann dir attestieren du gehört es schon so mit zu den ersten weil in dieser Zeit hat sich ja eigentlich im Prinzip das was man ich habe jetzt eben net Zähne gesagt und immer so ein bisschen
bekloppter überhaupt ein Wort dafür zu finden aber doch mal so die Leute die
früh geahnt haben da ist irgendwas das ist natürlich teilweise einfach aus dieser Begeisterung für Computer als solche
wo kann ich das auch ganz gut für mich selber nachvollziehen und dann musste man so ein bisschen Glück haben um eigentlich mit Kommunikation was zu tun sagen weil wenn du sagst na ja die Netze Anfang der 80er jahre das Wort
Netz war für die Leute in den 80er Jahren,
etwas was man an einem Tor auf spannte ja oder was unter Akrobaten aufgespannt war aber ein Computernetzwerk,
ist etwas das muss man noch vermitteln und der Chaos Computer Club war ja bei seiner Gründung schon in diesem ersten wunderbaren tuwat Pamphlet im Prinzip sehr weit voraus
wo sozusagen Computernetzwerke und ihre Wirkung im Prinzip ja schon vorausgesagt wurden und was teilweise auch noch gültig ist,
bis heute wann hast du denn das erste Mal dieses Gefühl gehabt was nett ist und wodurch wurde das ausgelöst.
Gut,
die ersten Datennetze die man bereist hat also Mailboxen haben da im Prinzip nicht so wirklich dazu gehört die Wanne immer stationär sondern ein. Das gabs auch Anfang der 80er schon so eine Handvoll nicht viele in Deutschland oder ein paar,
letzte dann später waren halt bitte net X25 das waren sie die ersten letzte die benutzt worden hat sich damals ein gewählt in einem Pad und konnte dann,
herüber paketorientierte Kommunikation schon international tatsächlich sich in andere Großrechner weltweit einloggen das ging auch schon Mitte der 8,
das war nicht das war natürlich ganz Klar Netz auch wenn es verbindungsorientiert war aber Internet kam hatte ich sehr viel später.
Ja aber ich will nicht übers Internet sein ich rede wirklich über dieses Netz Gefühle und ehrlich hatte das schon zu Mailbox Zeiten also ich weiß noch wie ich so
von Amelies ich fange musst du vielleicht kurz erklären also Mailbox ist man wird sich mit Modem halt nicht in ein Internetzugang ein sondern verbindet sich mehr oder weniger mit
einem Computer wo jemand anderem die ein oder mehrere Models angeschlossen hat und dort konnte man dann halt mails hinterlassen und darüber Kommunikationsaustausch machen und der totale.
So ein bisschen so wie die Leute das heute übers Internet mit facebook machen.
Ja da ist.
Vorläufer von Facebook.
Dass das ne Menge dran,
aber spätestens in dem Moment wo daneben auch mehrere Leute gleichzeitig im Sonnensystem online war und man auch chatten konnte miteinander
das war so das erste Mal wo wir schon so ein bisschen der kalte Schauer über den Rücken lief wo ich mir dachte sowohl was ist denn das jetzt bitteschön und was mich total,
weg katapultiert hat als ich dann irgendwann mal anfing diesen News Vorläufer des Internets das Usenet zu entdecken
wo man dann eben tatsächlich in öffentlichen Forum diskutieren konnte und ich blätterte in diesen diesen diesen Nachrichten Wald und drückte die ganze Zeit die Space-Taste und versuchte zu verstehen was ich denn da jetzt eigentlich gerade lese
dann habe ich irgendwie so ein Text gesehen und es war offensichtlich von irgendjemand der ist in Kalifornien geschrieben hat,
und dann war das irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen erst wie ein Buch und dann traf mich der Schlag als ich das Datum gesehen habe und die Nachricht war drei Tage alt.
Und die befand sich auf meinem Computer und das war dann so der Moment wo ich mir dachte so,
okay ich stehe jetzt in Kontakt mit jemand auf einem anderen Kontinent wann ging dir das so.
Ja das ist also ich Usenet kann bei mir tatsächlich spät 780 oder sowas vorher war ich im 400c,
hatte ähnliche Sachen Sattel Newsgroup ähnliche,
Ansätze auch aber man konnte Privatnachrichten schicken aber man hatte auch eben weltweite Nachrichten Gruppen in die jeder reinschreiben konnte und die waren eh nicht im Usenet themenorientiertes war und ich viel weniger also die Volumina sind überhaupt nicht Vergleich,
und das war dann auch tatsächlich dieser Effekt als man damit erstmal auf Usenet getroffen müssen das geht noch größer das geht noch besser das ist das,
interessanterweise damals war die ich würde mal vorsichtig ausdrücken,
die akademische Qualität war etwas hören also auf qualifiziertes.
Was ist lustig.
Navigation zu welchen Problemen.
Ja aber das sind interessanter. Ne weil man traf ja auf eine Community von sind mit sehr vielen intelligenten Menschen die sich mit komplexen Kram Beschäftigten und fast niemand sonst.
Haben damals noch da.
Es wurde auch schon ein bisschen geschrieben und die ersten Probleme traten auf aber,
es bildet sich sogar noch eine Kultur raus und und damit auch so eine Hoffnung fand ich.
Dort dass man auf etwas stieß was so eine höhere Qualität hatte als das was man sich um um sich herum so in der Masse wahrgenommen hat.
Also das gab es ja schon mal hatte diese diese Hoffnung dass man dieses also die hat ja ein Kommunikationsproblem wenn man versucht hat mit dem Ausland zu kommunizieren international zu kommunizieren wie sollte man Freunde wie sollte man Bekannte finden das gab's ja quasi,
vorher gar nicht und diese Netze haben das schon geleistet und hatte also ich habe damals auch die ersten Freunde in USA gefunden darüber die wo,
der themenspezifisch
bei mir waren glaube ich die ersten Teams aus dem Blatt eben oder sowas darüber reden konnte und dann kommt irgendwas ist denn die wo geht denn das jetzt hin was ist neues Prozessorgeneration sowas und da haben sich auch tiefen Freundschaften drüber entwickelt und
aber da hatte man schon diesen Eindruck ja man kann das Überwinden machen Grenzen über wenn das auch das was dann
in der ersten Generation Internet außer wenn den 90ern der Eindruck der entstanden ist dass man damit vielleicht Globalisierung schafft und,
das ist leider etwas was jetzt im letzten Jahren so bisschen rückläufig ist würde ich sagen also zumindest wird sehr stark wieder nationalisieren.
Ich fahre als ich habe das erste meme,
auf dass ich so gestoßen bin war imminent des of the net predicted so diese Angst,
das alles auf einmal alle Leute dazu kam und sich alles weiter immer kommerzialisierte und man gefühlt jeden Tag mehr neue User in diesem Netz hatte als vorher insgesamt existiert,
und das ja dann zwangsläufig irgendwann mal alles explodieren würde was dann irgendwie erstmal eine ganze Weile lang nicht passierte.
Den Effekt hatte ich das welche sehr sehr früh weil witzigerweise über so Nachrichten Gruppen weil am Anfang waren weltweit,
1000 Leute drin in irgend also eine populäre Gruppe wo es über,
Betriebssystem gegen oder sowas daran paar tausend Leute drin alles auf einmal 10000/100 oder kommt nicht mehr diskutieren das ist komplett,
sozusagen den Tod erlegen das zu viele Leute da drin waren und hat man sich abgespalten hat immer mehr IV und diese Explosion von von Diskussionsforen und,
da habe ich übrigens die ersten der ersten Mal so den Eindruck gehabt dass man diese bubbles irgendwie rein kommt das hatte ich zufällig sehr früh schon Anfang der 90er,
soll man sagt dann aber wir diskutieren hier und in der anderen Forum wird das anderes diskutiert das passt eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr zusammen also diese diese Effekte die gab es auch schon sehr früh.
Aber dass das Gefühl dass mir das Netz nicht mehr beherrschen kann das wirklich wenn man ganz tief drin steckt hat man das sehr selten ne also wenn wenn man es irgendwie,
wirklich baut die die Leitung betreibt direkt bei uns betreibt dich.
Kannst du mich anrufen nehmt ihr Bonn gegründet zu haben dass das gtt ist heute das wurde mal von mir gegründet,
und dann dann stellt man sich diese Frage nicht ob das Netz aber die Infrastruktur physikalische Funktion oder so wie funktioniert ob das beherrsche weißt dem Inhalt sieht so ein bisschen anders aus also die der Konten ist nun mit mediale Content da,
ja muss man glaube ich bei manchen Diensten die heute so existieren bisschen Infragestellen warum sie eigentlich in dieser Form und ob das so eine gute Idee war die irgendwie einkleben.
Dann erzähl doch mal ein bisschen was was du so gemacht hast also was er dann irgendwann auch ein bisschen älter und bist ja dann relativ intensiv in diese Netzausbau Zähne vor gestoßen.
Ja ist also erste Firma habe ich mit 16 gegründet,
gehört da dann auch irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu damals noch sehr viel mit tatsächlich Netzausbau da mache dann für Ärzte für Werbeagenturen und sowas Modems installiert das war noch kein echter Netzausbau aber,
das führte sehr schnell dazu das dann local area ne,
gebaut wurden darf ich gleich auf den ersten Fehltritt begangen habe ich natürlich übers Müll kommen alleine installiert also das ging in Frankfurt da waren die natürlich sehr sehr stark am Start,
und das führte dann dazu dass man aber tatsächlich mit mit mit dem Aufbau von internationalen Datensätzen noch mit Gateways mit Routern und so beschäftigt hat und sich die Frage stellt und kann man das nicht auch professionalisieren bei mir führt es dazu dass ich,
damals dann gerade diese Mailboxen und diese diese FidoNet Szene im Rhein-Main-Gebiet im Prinzip mit dem Netz überzogen hat sodass die Mailboxen dort alle dann easy4ip anstehen hatten.
Das war so die Kern Zelle des Providers und das 290,
Listenverbindung x 92 geschaltet 93 kann man der erste Fahrer nicht mehr im Rhein-Main-Gebiet zu Haus München dazu,
und dann war auf einmal deutschlandweit am Start aber das erfordert Inhalt auch dass man eigene international Leitung irgendwoher bekommt,
und das war auch ein sehr spannendes Thema das war ungefähr die Zeit als den USA beim dieses NSFNET also das sowas eigentlich nur akademisch war und hat sich auch für den Kommerz geöffnet wurde im Prinzip also das auch,
kommerzielle Provider sich dort anschließend unten und das benutzen konnten,
und es wird immer zu dass man durch die ersten Leitung nach Kalifornien geschaltet hat damals zu los netto die haben so einen schönen Namen.
TV-Wandhalter Edinburgh Lichter an der Uni und das waren fast alle Sony Ausgründung also dass man tatsächlich Ausland aus dem privat Umfeld oder als als Unternehmer damals schon in den Bereichen in Icepeak gegründet hat und das betrieben das war sehr sehr selten,
fast alle auch in Deutschland fast alle Netzwerkbetreiber dich damals gehabt kam Intel aus dem universitären Umfeld bist du wohl schon dass du XLink Allnet und so dass man die großen dies da gab,
oder dann halt später von Telcos Telekom dann aber erst ab 95 vorher da.
Darf in dieser Zeit auch nie Initiative von Leuten die,
wollten das eben Privatleute auch ins Internet kam als dem Zeitung war das Herr saß er schon Insertionen Militär,
Universitäten natürlich auch aber so diese Vorstellung dass man einen eigenen Internetanschluss zu Hause hat das war ja noch irgendwie komplett undenkbar.
Oder wann fangen.
Nicht für Klaus Lande.
Naja dich für Klaus Landefeld aber.
Nenne das persönliche schon angeboten Dienst oder zugangsdienst,
umgeschaltet unter so ab,
tun als 390 ist es ja so gewesen dass tatsächlich Leute im dial-in also Slip damals in den Mailboxen im Rhein-Main-Gebiet machen konnten und dort ihren persönlichen IP Zugang dann hatten das war.
Übernehme also Mailbox.
Taschen für steht ja schon Infrastruktur sollte man in die allerbesten dual-use bringen also wir haben quasi die gleichen Models verwendet und die die wir im Mailbox Programm haben das dann damals angefangen zu unterstützen dass du so ein,
wenn du wenn du eben clipconnect hattest sind die dann raus gesprungen und sind direkt in die Epi Verbindung gegangen ja das ist so so 90-93,
war das zu früh für dich Entschuldigung.
Für mich viel zu früh für mich und ich frage mich was haben die Leute denn damals mit dem Netz gemacht.
Das ist eine Voranfrage.
Wenn da so wenig also weit über das halt auf eine gewisse Weise interessant.
Vorwärts Nordhorn.
War nicht bunt und es war noch es war noch relativ wenig Leute ne.
Es ist also sehr viel ist natürlich nicht die US unten E-Mail verwendet worden das war natürlich die die Killer Apps damals war E-Mail dass man,
Fertig die Welt kommunizieren konnte aber man hat auch tatsächlich damals mit Telnet sich eben das war tatsächlich offen man konnte sich,
auf Unix rechnen irgendwo auf der Welt mit einem Gastzugang einloggen und konnte dann den Uni Rechner benutzen das war normal,
irgendwann Australien irgendwelche Applikationen auf einem Großrechner benutzen konnte auch als Gast vom anderen Ende der Welt war damals normal heute undenkbar natürlich.
Damals hatten wir interessanterweise dieses Problem dass das negativ empfunden wurde oder ist das dann als als hacking betrachtet wurde das muss ich da ein Loch.
Hat man nicht wobei muss ich hab so persönliches saures hat mir natürlich auch so meine erste Hausdurchsuchung 39030 genau da konnte ich gar nichts für.
Nein.
Nein man kann ja nie was dafür aber nein in dem Fall war tatsächlich interessant weil die,
aber dass Du Dich ein Kunde war der Student der bei der GSI in Darmstadt gibt sie gesagt hatte Schwerionenforschung und das eine Bundes Forschungseinrichtung und der hatte dort gearbeitet,
Duden Verständnis Kraft ist weg gegangen und hat sich anschließend und eingeloggt und Daten auf seinem Hund verdammt das wurde dann als hacking einer bundesforschungs andere.
Weil das ja von von meinem IP-Bereich kam,
wo dann die Hausdurchsuchung bei mir gemacht das war sehr spannend weil die klingelt morgens um 8 Uhr oder sowas ähnliches und wollten den Rechner mitnehmen.
Und ich sagte welche meinen Sie denn.
Und was geht's hier eigentlich und dann erstmal versucht zu erklären dass er auf den Netzknoten von dem Internet Provider sind der war damals bei mir im Keller.
Das haben sie nicht verstanden war noch so ein bisschen ratlos was er da machen soll das jetzt alle diese Rechner oder Stunden insurex bestimmt schon so,
tema unter ganze Bruder im Bänke und Hammer ungefähr 100/200 Telefonleitung da ungefähr damals terminiert,
damit kann ich umgehen an die Kollegen vom LKA geholt die die dann tatsächlich anderthalb Stunden später aus Wiesbaden damals dann da waren.
Diverse morgens um 10 Uhr da sind abends um 21 Uhr gegangen nachdem Crashkurs was ist Internet wie funktioniert was kann man machen wenn das.
Aber auch das ist das ist für die Zukunft hat sich sehr interessant weil weil das führte dann dazu dass man jetzt muss auf diese Seite mal sehen,
weiter ist man ja heute immer verpflichtet zusammenzuarbeiten Strafverfolgungsbehörden das war eine Prinzip so die ersten die Schritte in diesem Bereich das kann dir aber auch nicht immer Ergebnis hatte ich dann zwei tolle Kunden das Landeskriminalamt Wiesbaden und das BKA die ihre.
Hatte ihre ersten Internetverbindungen von mir hatten dann und.
Letzte geil dass die Sachen das machen wir auch oder.
Die brauchen das schon aber das war nicht ich das war noch mal ein bisschen später dann also an also die große.
Ok also Hausdurchsuchung für als Kundenakquise.
Genau man kann aus allem was machen.
Hallo wir wollen mit Ihnen über Ihre Bodensenke reden ja noch haben wir fort frei.
Nee aber das nette Sachen aber auf deiner Seite hat man natürlich dann auch erklärt wie funktioniert das eigentlich aber es war auch klar nativ Strafverfolgung muss und welche Möglichkeiten haben man muss da irgendwie,
durch Zusammenarbeit mit Provider und da natürlich auch irgendwie weiterkommen können.
Persönlich meinen Stöpsel etwas später gestorben und 98 als dann die Kollegen aus Pullach dann das erste Mal da stand und sich auch informieren lassen wollten übers Internet ist nicht ein Esel.
Du hast ja dann Internetprovider also war das jetzt schon der Nakama das.
Das Mama, das an die ersten Schritte von Nakama ja genau das wurde ja dann später zu World online Addons Italy aber das ist das waren dann so spät ist 98 und 2000 und die Zeit.
Heute was relativ früh auch in diesem Businessbereich halt unterwegs und hast quasi so dies die die wirkliche Internet Infrastruktur die sich dann so ab Mitte der Mitte der 90er Jahre herausgebildet hat aktiv mit Begleit,
wann wurde der Eco EVO gegründet.
Nico wurde M95 gegründet.
Also Eco ist der.
Verband Internetwirtschaft und,
das eigentlich wurde Eco so außenrum um diese Frage gegründet es gab damals eine Handvoll 67 Provider in Deutschland und die mussten die Daten austauschen weil Daten aus Dorfweiher teuer.
Nur um Altenfeld dass ich glaube die meine Kinder können sich das vorstellen meine erste 2 Megabit Leitung nach USA also vorher hatte man so 128er 72 km 102 Megabit Leitung nach USA also von Frankfurt nach New York,
pro Monat damals 250.000 Marke.
Moment das war das Sonderangebot von das hat noch nur in Frankfurt gekriegt damals von MfS bei der damals gerade neu geschirmt Telekom waren wir beim Preis 46000.
Pro Monat 2 m.
Deswegen sag ja das ist der Sonne Angebot gewesen ja genau her nach London also vielmehr hat das Sopro Megabit ungefähr fünf.
Und selbst in die Niederlande rüber nach Amsterdam oder so wann wann war mal so bei 16000,
am fünfundzwanziger mit Leitungen an das ist schon das ein ganz andere kann sich heute einig keiner mehr vorstellen aber das als Provider musste man das im Prinzip einkaufen und mehrere davon natürlich,
um überhaupt den Kunden dann Dienstanbieter.
Ja Sophia aus der Abteilung wir hatten ja nichts.
Genau und dann macht es aber Sinn natürlich dass man das in Frankfurt austauschen nicht alles erst nach USA schickt und zurück hier also.
Das heißt was war zuerst hat das DCX oder der IQ.
Erico ist man braucht irgendwie haben also die Keks ist ein Projekt von Ico das heißt natürlich die Frage passt zeitlich nicht so ganz rein warum hat eko gemacht damit damit die Klicks im Prinzip betrieben werden Kontenrahmen dafür da.
Müssen aber eine Sache muss erstmal ausräumen warum die Kicks das heißt doch den.
Nein das ist halt schon ein gutes hat die amerikanische aussprechen Internet exchange,
ja da kommt es her das ist die und als internationales Unternehmen sind ja mittlerweile in 14 Standorten international hat man sich halt für diese für die EM.
Okay aber wenn man DCX was sagt dann wird man nicht gleich mit Obers beworfen oder so.
Nenne den Politiker kann man sie auch nicht bleiben.
Okay na ja wie auch immer mal bleiben wir meinetwegen bei digitalo.de Keks der große deutsche Netz Austausch Knoten wann ist der gestartet.
95 das war knapp 10 Megabit hab in der Mainzer Landstraße.
Hat das so ein hat das Wort da unten stehen aber mit mit dem Gigabit.
Hat weiß ich nicht recht so alter Gigabit genau das war die erste die erste Ausführung an.
Ja also im Prinzip die Idee halt überhaupt erst mal so nett Knoten zu machen und warst du da von Anfang an mit dabei.
Das ist warte auf das auf dass es eine schöne Anekdote,
ich ich war in einem Raum wo Datenleitung von mir durchliefen in inrex drin und dann erzählte mir die Eigentümer von dieser Lokation ganz stolz er hätte jetzt den Internetknoten da hier auf der anderen Seite vom Raum dieses reckt das heißt das neue deutsche Internet.
Müssen im moment mal also nur 5505 Provider wir treffen uns laufen davon weiß ich überhaupt kann eigentlich nicht sein aber ich habe gerade noch ein Ethernet.
Kabel durch den doppelten Boden gelegt in den Napf reingesteckt Nahbereich Teilnehmernummer 2 an dem Knoten ohne dass ich eigentlich aber damals hat das alles sehr informell.
Novosan.
Das hat sich hinterher ja die drei Provider die es eigentlich ursprünglich machen wollten also wahrscheinlich wollten nur drei das sozusagen so als closed shop machen um Kostenvorteil zu haben aber das hat sich damit quasi erledigt.
Aber auf jeden Fall ne brauchbare Vision heute bis zum Aufsichtsrates und wie lange machst du das jetzt schon.
Oh Gott in verschiedenen Versionen ich bin im Vorstand von Eko seit 97,
und seit diesem Zeitpunkt auch für die Kids verantwortlich also im ersten der Vorstandsfunktionen dann haben wir aus gegründet als GmbH die dicke Management GmbH in 2003,
und dass das dann an der AG geworden ist also noch mal eine Nummer weiter das hat sich aus der Internationalisierung von dickes ergeben dass man 20.12,
ja gemacht dass seitdem in streng im Aufsichtsrat vorher war das ganzen Beirat aber.
Und alles mit dieser 2 Megabit leid.
Nee dann nicht mehr so ganz nee aber das,
alter kommt diese diese im Tirol Seite hätte ich auch rein ins nochmals World online haben wir sehr stark ausgebaut auch europaweite wandern 17 Ländern und haben den ersten 622 MB trac umgebaut in 98 das war damals.
Also nach der damaligen sehr viel und das war da damit der größte Bäcker und dem harten Leben wie die,
und ja.
Wenn man wenn man jetzt
nicht nur so 50 Kunden hat alle Wasser im Keller bedient sein wenn sozusagen dann das ganze Internet in Deutschland darüber läuft könnte ich mir vorstellen dass die Kollegen noch mal vorbeigekommen sind irgendwann und fragen hatten.
Wie das jetzt funktioniert was ihr dann Keller gebaut.
Ja wir hatten doch,
es ist ja jetzt mittlerweile kein großes Geheimnis mehr aber es gab ja sag mal Interesse an diesen Datenfluss der dort stattgefunden hat.
Wann ist denn dieses Interesse so das erste Mal euch gerade Wort.
Gut also dass diese tatsächlich erstmal in 2008 auf uns zu getreten also als zickig sind,
man muss man muss wissen sabrieren als einzelner Carrier ist man immer verpflichtet mit denen zusammen zu arbeiten und da kann man auch immer Anordnung bekommen wenn auch immer für die Strafverfolgung Anordnung bekommen kann,
die interessante Frage hier ist kann man das auf einem Netzknoten machen weil eigentlich im Rahmen der telefoniert und Überwachung der Netzknoten nicht ausgeschlossen steht in der TKÜ auch drinnen direkt am Anfang einer Zusammenschaltung Punkte sind ausgeschlossen.
Und deswegen war das ein bisschen überraschend als sie dann das erstmal auf uns zukommen oder gesagt habe.
Was wollte ich eigentlich was wollte ich eigentlich doch jeden einzelnen Carrier eigentlich als verpflichteten und wenn es um um individual Überwachung geht dann müsste ja auch zu den Keller gehen das könnte einen Knoten gar nicht machen weil,
wir wissen gar nicht wer der Kunde ist na das sind ja nur genau genau richtig langsam keinen Kontakt zu finden nicht herstellen,
und deswegen wird es auch diese strategische Überwachung dann limitiert im hinterher draußen diese Frage ging eigentlich ja nur für Auslands Leitungen und so weiter und jedes gesunde von Anfang an hatten wandern.
Hier in Lanz Netzknoten ja überwiegende Teil der Verkehre dir Langlaufen sind in Landverkehre er was wollte ich eigentlich so zickig überwachungs Ausgangsleistung zulässig,
aber das war so die Diskussionen anfangen hatten aber anders hat uns glaube ich zu meinem ersten Einladungen.
So fragen Haltung hat an den Seiten eines Sattels änderungsberechtigung und das war halt,
Riesenhunde Lage ich mal irgendwo diese Frage immer hat sie die Frage nicht umgestellt sollte die erste Terrorismus Welle auch damals es gab es war genauso die Zeit als es.
Jetzt auf einen anderen auf der Content viele gabst Urteile in Köln z.b. wo wurde es erstmal war das wirklich Kinder geworben wurden für terroristische Inhalte und da ging es um die Frage,
da wurde wirklich in in Arabisch auf den Servern,
da wurden Kinder Futter für terroristische Zwecke angeworben im Prinzip und da ging's an Daggi samsoe übersetzungs fragen er ist das steht das jetzt da was da eigentlich steht ja und so wurde das dann,
in die Länge gezogen und das waren Diskussionen die wir die wir sehr stark hatten also jetzt auf auf Eco Ebene und,
der Kontext wurde im Prinzip benutzt zu sagen wir müssen hier was tun im müssen was für Terrorismus tun und die Bundesregierung haben es damals versichert dass das alles seine Rechtmäßigkeit hätte.
Also nicht für Terrorismus sein eher gegen.
Ja natürlich ayaklara soviel zur Terrorismusbekämpfung aber heute würde man sagen zum Totschlag oment wird immer ausgepackt wenn es um irgendwelche Überwachungsmaßnahmen geht es immer Terrorismus oder ganz weit,
auch wenn das gar keinen nachweise dafür gibt das ist dagegen was.
Wie sehr schlägt sich denn diese kulturelle Prägung der 80er und 90er Jahre die ja,
erfüllt war von so diesem Traum eines freien und Behinderten Netzes was die Menschen zusammenbringt und die Völker verständigt also Albert Einstein hatte ja mit dem Radio auch schon,
diese selbe Vision diesen Traum so wenn erstmal alles enden dann dann dann können sich die
Völker aus ihrer Stumpfheit erlösen etc dann kam irgendwie Hitler mit dem Volksempfänger und hat es erstmal für seine Propagandazwecke,
missbraucht erfolgreich und noch heute sehen wir das ja noch und jetzt wie welche Rolle,
bierzauber Malteser urgeist in the organisation wie demeco und auch in deinen persönlichen Aktivismus du bist ja auch im Bundestag wirst du befragt zu,
Einschätzung et cetera bei in Ausschüssen.
Wie viel von diesem Geist lebt in dieser Provider Seele noch.
Ja ich muss jetzt erstmal sagen Glück weil einige noch so das war so diese no future Ecke erstmal das hat mich bloß nie getroffen aber,
dieser dieser Geist der ist nicht so Mitte der 90er entstanden das war alles das war alles neu mal das war so eine wunderschöne Aufbruch irgendwas man es auch die die Unternehmen alle gewachsen man hatte immer hat unheimlich viel Spaß zusammen,
und das man hat dich auf diese dort kommen Zeit man hat das egal was man angefasst hat das wird alles um wie finanziert man kann das alles aufbauen konnte alles ausprobieren das war glaube ich dein,
darf man auch ein bisschen spielen konnte man konnte wirklich jede an alles Mögliche versuchen und,
um um dann mal ein Beispiel zu bringen wir haben als also worldonline damals haben keinen Content kaufen können um in unseren Kunden anbieten zu können Namedy Konzerte kurzem kurz an selber gemacht damit U2 und Eurythmics und was ich Konzerte gemacht,
wenn man's Konzert gemacht hat dann dann durfte man stream ja also das waren dass man so Ansätze dann hat er einfach gemacht und das hat das hat auch funktioniert,
brother oder sowas ähnliches zu streamen haben aber das war damals war das damals war das die ersten,
Streams in großem Stil 24/7 Streaming für mehrere tausend Streams parallel das war absolut neu.
Stimmt das konnte man sich damals über das Internet an.
Genau genau und halt auch in die Bilder klicken und hat dann links Synchro,
dal innovativ aber ja aber das ist heute wissen was heißt aktiv zusammen aber,
auf seiner das war halt völlig neues war das waren dass man Größenordnung des konnte sich keiner vorstellen der Firma wirklich hunderte von Megabit und produziert und Datenverkehr und die da waren und so also.
Das ist sehr sehr schnell dann zu Ende bekommen eigentlich erst durch durch so diesem nine eleven und unter Platzen der Dotcom bubble Geschichten und das hat die ganze Branche also bisschen in die Depression geworfen,
tatsächlich sollen wir waren die ersten Entlassungswelle sehr viel unternehmen sind umgegangen und so weiter und hat nur sich nie wieder so richtig raus lösen können das war immer alles danach war immer wesentlich schwieriger,
und danach kam auch eigentlich die Generation der der Großunternehmen sage ich mal irgendwo,
weil dann auch Medienhäuser rein gegangen sind weil die großen Telcos auf einmal die die dominanten Provider waren und sowas ist,
so um die Jahrtausendwende würde ich sagen gerade so der der Bruch da drin dass man diesen diesen diesen Lifestyle auch dieses dieses positive irgendwo Datum so ein bisschen verloren hat uns eigentlich so eine so eine normale Branche.
Aber der IQ eV selber fällt aus meiner Perspektive immer noch dadurch auf doch eine recht freiheitlich geprägte Grund Einstellung zu verbreiten.
Ja das liegt natürlich auch daran dass die Leute die dort sind die dort arbeiten die auch im Vorstand sind alle dass das so sehen also wir vertreten alle diese diese Auffassung,
und haben uns auch immer,
eine Meinung im Prinzip rausgenommen haben viele Verbände sind so nicht organisiert die sind sehr stark von Groß Mitgliedern dominiert das haben wir von Anfang an bei Migros,
im Prinzip ausgeschlossen dadurch dass alle Mitglieder gleich sin jeder hat auch nur eine Stimme also also nicht abhängig davon wie viel jemand zahlt oder sowas ähnliches und das hat,
und als Eko tatsächlich viel gebracht weil wenn man
wenn es nur auf die Anzahl ankommt dann hat man dich auch sehr viele kleine Provider dir von Unternehmern oder auch von von Netzaktivist oder sowas mal gegründet wurden das also die die die Nähe zur zur Szene ist wesentlich größer und das konnten wir dann auch
weiterziehen und dann gibt es nicht auf Themen die wir neue Saeco besetzt haben oder gerade so Content Sachen und so was ist da gibt's nicht so viele andere Verbände unter.
Ich will trotzdem noch mal so diese.
In diesem Zeitraum den den wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben von irgendwie zwei Megabit Leitung für eine viertel Millionen Mark,
zu was was setzte was setzt der der DAX in wie anfangen 2000 Ananda untenrum was ist da der ist das Datenvolumen.
MS weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr glaube ich glaube so zu tausendmal so ungefähr die Gigabit Port eingeführt das war so der erste Phase und wo wir wo wir die ersten Gigabit,
ganz neue experimentell im eingeführt haben habe ich jetzt nicht mehr im Kopf müssen meine Statistiken.
Haben heute so bei 600 terrabit die durchläuft werden heute machen wir viermal Gigabit Anschlüsse für also als Einzel port,
das Dorf.
Ist ordentlich.
Wächst ja genau aber das halt nur fragen wie man sich das was was was dich auszeichnet verteilt ist in 20 Data Centern in Frank,
und diese diese Idee dass man eben nicht an einem Punkt sein muss sondern dass im Prinzip jeder seiner Erhard werden data-center stellen kann die Leitungen irgendwie nur in dem data center ankommen interest
machen wir es also eigentlich ein Battle Portinari exchanger noch mal genau nimmt
haben das ist das was was das hier für Antrag deshalb so interessant ist außerdem darin ich vergessen wie viele sind es halt mittlerweile 1850 Carrier wieder zusammenkommen,
und das ist.
Als 2013 die News über uns hereinbrach von Edward Snowden und seinen Gedichten Informationen wie viel Neues war da für dich dabei.
Also ja da war schon neue Sachen dabei insbesondere weiters geht also solche sowas wie.
Dassault Zugriffe auf interne Datenleitungen das war z.b. ein riesen Thema das also,
Leitung ausgeleitet wurden die die immer die von einem data center zum anderen data center innerhalb eines Netzes das ist eigentlich gar nicht wenn man sich die Logik von Überwachung anguckt ist das eigentlich gar nicht zulässig aber von der von der Rechtslage her,
weil das innerhalb eines eines Unternehmens im Prinzip ist es gab auch der der Umfang also auf die Korrelation die gemacht wurde waren wandern Thema,
vielleicht am am kritisch gesehen habe ich damals das was bisher YouTube gemacht hat also das Abhören am Unterseekabel und dass man sich aber auch zu speichern so dass man so ein Replay da drauf machen kann,
das ist ja dass er insoweit kritisch als wenn ich irgendwo was finde und ich kann ein bisschen zurück gucken dann sehe ich halt mit wem wurde da kommuniziert dann kann ich das im Prinzip wieder meine aktuelle Überwachung einspeisen und das,
das ist der entscheidende Punkt da drin für diese Möglichkeit zurück gucken zu können die ist elementarer deswegen wird ja auch über Vorratsdatenspeicherung immer diskutiert,
und das ist ja doch das reicht die Größe nimmt.
Also das hat dich überrascht.
Das hat mich überrascht ich bin nicht davon ausgehen dass du deinen Unterseekabel nennt dieser Form statt,
insbesondere weil das auch eine Nebenform vom Aufwand her die dazu getrieben werden muss um diese Speicherung vorzunehmen dass das richtig gemacht wurde an dieser,
das ist auch interessant den USA wäre das in dieser Form nicht gegangen von der Rechtslage Herd während Deutschland nicht gegangen Rechtslage her und Großbritannien eigentlich auch nicht aber,
das ist ja extra zu Real für die war das am am am Unterseekabel ist und da wird dir dann wird ja nur weitergeleitet also sind Prinzip Beachfeld am Beach.
Duty-free-Shop.
Dann genau da konnte man es ausleiten also innerhalb Großbritanniens ist auch nicht zulässig gewesen und das man das dann,
uns an dieser Stelle dann dann etwas Aufbau das eine Speicherung macht die auch nach nationalem Recht eigentlich unzulässig wäre dass das ist dann schon unerwartet.
Und was war für dich nicht unerwartet oder was was was was was wusstest du schon und durftest dann endlich auch mal darüber.
Na gut also das ist zu dem Zeitpunkt dann schon Überwachungsmaßnahmen zugegeben hat auch in auch in Frankfurt oder dass das war hilfreich da drüber reden zu können weil das musste man immer hinter irgendwo hinter der Tür halten und,
hat auch versucht dagegen was zu machen oder auch eben im Kanzleramt und auch immer wieder mit dem BND selber zusammen und das Thema eigentlich nicht so ganz aber dann,
für uns war damals wichtig das Wetter sich erkannt haben die die Sorgen die wir hatten das,
dass das berechtigt war also auch in die Einschätzung skypen NSA Untersuchungsausschuss und hat erst mal vier Experten gehört der faire Rechtsexperten gehört und dann hatten sich die Statements von den Rechtsexperten angeguckt und hat gesagt.
Das macht genau die Probleme die wir da damit auch gesehen haben und,
dass das was gemacht wird mit den Daten das wusste man im Prinzip ja dann über Snowden und konnte das eben auch wieder einführen könnte das Weiterführen also.
Lyft das wusstet ihr also zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht wirklich.
Na gut die daten Verlassen dein Haus und weißt du nicht mehr so genau was was damit natürlich passiert,
es gab schon paar Sachen die fanden wir seltsamen die wir immer angegriffen haben wir auch Richtung G10 Kommission zum angegriffen haben das mal eben sagt naja ich habe z.b. verschiedene Anordnungen zu verschiedenen Phänomen Bereichen,
aber ich nehme die Daten nur einmal und Leid das auch noch einmal aus und eigentlich müssten da verschiedene Selektoren verschiedene Regionen verschieden sonst was da drauf stehen.
Ist alles dasselbe das ist alles dasselbe wieso ist das so und das ist diese geheim,
haltungs Verpflichtung ist ja immer drauf und dann gibt's halt eben wann kann ich da drüber reden,
wir haben geklagt die Richter in Leipzig hatten kein Problem damit da drüber zu reden also können wir auch da drüber reden ja also dass solche das.
Keine zwei also dass die Zweckbindung umgangen wird im Prinzip das mal einfach sag mal wenn wir die Daten ausmachen können machen was sie wollen das sind so so Punkte wo man dann sagen muss es aber das ist praktische,
praktische Nutzung mittig Snowden im hat man erst noch ein bisschen erfahren dass Du hinterher damit gemacht hast wird denn eigentlich die können diese Daten nicht bearbeitet werden was passiert mit diesen Daten,
das war in Teilen dass ich auf dich bin oder sowas schon bekannt ja es war weiß nicht alles neu,
ich hatte hatte mit dem Bild vorher schon gesprochen und so ja also was ist Inhalt einfach Sachen oder Samus okay war diese Kombination aus allem und dann natürlich viele,
was war für mich auch neu war war dass das tatsächlich auch von anderen Unternehmen die ausführten auf einmal bereit war mit mir zu reden,
aber das war alles halt. So populär oder es wurde diskutiert man konnte dann,
ähm auf einmal auch eigentlich mit Mitgliedsunternehmen jetzt aus Eco Sicht sprechen und vieler mal gesagt wo dass das scheiße ist jetzt hier geschäftsschädigend für uns haben das immer mitgemacht aber jetzt auf einmal ist das ein Thema auf ein weißes Vincent Problem dass man dako operiert,
unheimliche überlegen müssen ja warum macht er das aber,
man konnte halt ins Gespräch kommen an Conti Leute kennenlernen man man dass das hilft auch bis heute natürlich dass man wirklich sagen kann was.
Als er angefangen hat im Prinzip das Internet zu bauen.
War euch da klar dass das diese Bedeutung einmal entwickeln würde einmal für die Gesellschaft gut das,
konnte man sich wahrscheinlich vorstellen wenn man die insbesondere früh die Potenziale gesehen hat und wie weit man damit der Welt voraus war aber was,
das dass ihr irgendwann in solchen Situationen sein würdet in irgendwie euch vor Gerichten wiederfinden würde gegen Geheimdienste in Überwachungsskandal.
Also das ist nee habe ich nicht also oft schon so ein bisschen so in dieser Zauberlehrlings Pension gesehen was hast gemacht oder er soll das Ganze eigentlich sein aber natürlich überwiegt erstmal der Vorteil ja ich möchte es auch nicht missen und nun möchte natürlich das Netz auch,
benutzen kann in irgendeiner Form aber.
Es ist doch welchen interessante und interessanteste welchen welchen Ländern ist Überfalls Problem gesehen also ich habe selber mit Geheimdiensten mehreren Ländern zusammenarbeiten müssen mit Strafverfolger nein,
weil man dich wenn man 17 Ländern ist dann kommen in vielen Ländern.
Überwiegend europäische Länder aber was ich in der Niederlande Frankreich Italien sonst gerade mit ein paar Ländern habe ich das halt auch selber gemacht damals als das Lied Hero von von World online,
und da ist es also von der Philosophie her also wenn man in Frankreich mit.
Wenn in Sentiment ähnlich also da regt sich auch keiner so richtig drüber auf aber auch das geht aber auch schon für Strafverfolgung wenn die Polizei um die Ecke kommen sagt wir wollen die Daten haben oder über und dann interessiert es erstmal kein,
der Niederrhein ist ein bisschen anders deswegen ist da auch der Aktivismus sehr stark in Großbritannien ist es auch anders,
auch wenn da die gesetzlichen Regelungen mittlerweile sehr weit gehen aber historische auch von der von den Aktivitäten her ist man da sehr viel stärker darauf zu sagen nee das dass wir machen nicht einfach was was die Dienste von uns verlangen,
aber in weiten Teilen der Welt in USA ist genau das gleiche wenn die Geheimnisse um die Ecke kommen lassen.
Da gibt's zwar starke Bürgerrechtsorganisation die dann die Gesetzeslage wieder anfassen nur auf der Telekom dazu also von der Provider Seite her.
Sind da kaum jemandem der bereit ist sich doch mal gegen was.
Das heißt Deutschland ist die große Ausnahme.
Der Deutschland nicht allein also es gibt auch für Niederlande oder sowas oder irgendwas ähnliches oder eben,
Tanja so es gibt schon ist es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Ländern wo man wo wo es eben sehr starke sentiments dagegen gibt und wo man dann auch aktiv ist aber tatsächlich ist es in auch viele unserer Rechte,
existieren ja einen anderen ersetzen europäischen Ländern oft nicht in dieser Form mehr hatten diese Diskussion jetzt ganz aktuell im Rahmen von die evidence also er wusste um die Ausleitung von gespeicherten genau gespeicherten Daten verloren forßmann Gründe gibt.
Und da ist also das was wir in Deutschland haben sie kernbereichsschutz dafür warten Lebensgestaltung z.b. der ja auch im digitalen Raum eingegebene Tagebücher sonst hast du sogar das längste Buch das gibt immer aus,
also das ist so und das wird gar nicht verstanden dass Du doch in der europäischen das gesungen gar nicht verstanden was wir da eigentlich genau schützen wollen und warum warum die warum die Strafverfolgung das idealerweise noch nicht mehr die Hand kriegen dürfte,
und da gibt's heute 0 Harmonisierung im selbst im europäischen Fall also wir brauchen,
eigentlich im Ausland also mit mit nichteuropäischen Ausland gar nicht unterhalten oder gar nicht großartig versuchen Verträge zu machen wenn wir es noch nicht mal innerhalb der EU fertigbringen da irgendwie ein einheitlichen Level zu finden was man als akzeptabel betrachtet und und.
Aber was denkst du denn was da so die kulturelle Hürde ist an der Stelle ist das jetzt einfach mal hier so unsere spezifische Prägung durch die Nachkriegszeit oder Kriegszeit vielmehr.
Ist wohl aus der Nazizeit natürlich und dann namentlich aus Stasi,
sind sind wir da sehr starke gegen den Schaden dieser Stelle geprägt und haben auch ein Problem mit Überwachung was was gut ist,
und das ist das fehlt halt eben in vielen Ländern vollständig wenn man diese Erfahrung nicht gemacht hat glaube ich dann,
dann so viele sind ja auch sehr stark Hurricane wenn wenn wenn die Polizei der Geheimdienst irgendwas will dann bekommen die das halt einfach,
das ist aber das ist eine allgemeine Sache wäre mir auch auch selbst unsere normale also
Polizei auf der Straße schlafen haben wir ja sehr distanzierte Einstellung normalerweise und sagen ist das in der überhaupt in Ordnung darf der das muss ich das jetzt umsetzen was mir gesagt wird oder sowas ähnliches und dass das fehlt in vielen.
Wasser in unserem Land fehlt ist ja der Zugang zum Internet der ist ja nicht so ausgeprägt.
Kann ich jetzt nicht nachvollziehen.
Jetzt bist du ja jahrelang genau damit beschäftigt gewesen das große Glasfaser Strecken quer durch Deutschland gelegt zitterer.
Was machst du da immer noch was läuft hier schief.
Erhöhe breitenried dass es seine Freunde Frage ich habe selber Studien geschrieben 2003 für Hessen Landesregierung 2006 das BMWi,
muss um diese Frage das müsste man eigentlich machen und die Antwort war immer relativ klar würden uns ASIN angeguckt die Antwort war immer ist muss Glasfaser gelegt werden jeder Euro der und woanders rein investiert wird ist ein Problem.
Man hätte das von Anfang an auf Glasfaser umziehen können und sie müssen eigentlich an das Problem wir haben dann erstmal in 2006 erstmalig ein Breitband Ziel gesetzt das war dann ein Megabit,
ja das war damals schon,
schon als gesetzt wurde lächerlich also auch klar dass es nicht funktioniert und es wurde beim Setzen dieser Ziele nie so richtig die technischen Grundlagen oder ist das echt dahinter steht würde ich betrachte das nur sagen konnte er das,
das funktioniert nicht weil immer noch zu weit weg zu weit weg von der Vermittlungsstelle das funktioniert mit DSL nicht das funktioniert.
Und davon hat man sich erst eigentlich vorletztes Jahr gelöst wurden erstmalig.
Das sind aber so die Witze aber es hat ja vorhin schon gesehen.
Aber okay Glasnudeln ja genau die hätte man sehr viel früher anfangen das Problem was wir heute haben ist ja eigentlich dass man.
Jetzt auf einmal jetzt die Politik hat jetzt umgestellt hat endlich verstanden wir müssen Glas machen müssen konsequent Glas legen.
Was Moment Moment Moment die Politik hat etwas verstanden.
Naja das ist schon ist es ist zerbrechlich ist es in 27 erinner 27 gab es dieses dieses Umdenken im,
Exposition 1717 Herd.
Bin ich selber über die ganze Zeit über Vergangenheit reden ist man immer selber raus und ist nicht mehr als ich meine Dinge 20.17 an natürlich ja,
unter und mir stellt man fest geld allein macht nicht glücklich ich muss das ja auch unter die Erde bringen,
wenn diese Vorwürfe momentan laufen das Förderprogramm würde das Geld nicht ausgeben das ist einfach nicht richtig wehren 150 Landkreisen von von V von 298 die es gibt haben wir schon jetzt Glas,
Programme am Start die laufen schon als wenn bis Ende des ja auch wahrscheinlich über 200 sein interessant ist er sie die Frage was passiert in den 100 kreisfreien Städten und so wer blickt da.
Das dauert halt die Haare das zulegen wenn ich wenn ich wirklich so ein FTTH in den Landkreis irgendwo im Nichts bauen will dann bin ich halt 23 Jahre mindestens.
Vorausgesetzt ich habe dann die Bagger.
Das sieht dann halt wenn alle das gleichzeitig wollen ist kann ich nicht mehr bauen und das ist eigentlich das größte Problem was momentan existiert.
Also fehlt uns anbaggern.
Ja sieht man sich mal anders wir haben im Moment so ungefähr 3 Millionen Haushalte mit Glasfaser versorgt in Deutsch also ran daran bei warte mal das ungefähr die Zahl von,
Butter Trichinen im Gebäude schon Glasfaser reinläuft aber wir haben 40 Millionen also du musst ob es mal so wenn es auf Wohngebäude macht sind 28 Millionen,
du müsstest ungefähr also nur so pi mal Daumen wenn du bis 20:25 Uhr fertig werden willst müsstest also im Prinzip jedes Jahr so fünf bis sechs Mal so viel Anschlüsse bauen wie das was wenn letzten 10 Jahren gebaut haben um fertig zu werden müssen.
Dass das nicht zu leisten ist ohne weiteres wer soll das machen du hast mich auf einmal in die Industrie da stehen die legt die Millionen Glasfaseranschlüsse jedes Jahr legt.
Wenn nur weil jetzt auf einmal sagst ich möchte Tieren ich möchte jetzt Glas in der Großstadt oder sowas ähnliches legen die erzählt dir was,
die haben nur die haben Bau Baupläne über 20 Jahre wann Sie welche Straße wo aufreißen wollen und so weiter und dann kommst du um die Ecke und sagst ach ich würde jetzt aber gerne überall Glasfaser sofort liegen innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre oder sowas.
Das ist überhaupt nicht darstellbar also ganz von der planerischen von der von der Städte planerischen Sachen soweit das funktioniert überhaupt.
Was ist mit so an setzen Sie microtrenching wo sie im Prinzip versuchen das irgendwie nur so ein bisschen in den Asphalt rein zu drücken.
Ja das machst du natürlich erstmal im Innenstadtbereich auch nicht und auf dem Land bringt es ja eigentlich wenig weil dann liegt neben der Straße oder was hast du noch mal ein Grünstreifen oder sowas ähnliches dazwischen also das ist,
ja es bringt was es ist natürlich viel schneller als hat hinterher höhere Kosten im im operationellen Bereich weil der öfter mal was an der Faser machen musst aber das ist aber dann,
und wenn man anruft Beispiel zu in Japan Zimmerschlüssel Glasfaser überwiegend oben an jemanden gehängt worden wenn du Glasfasern die machst'n hängst dann tauschst du diese alle sechs bis acht Jahre aus,
und bald ist dann nachher fertig von der wird vom Wetter her und so und wenn man die Kosten über 20 Jahre sich angucken ist völlig identisch,
es ist nur so dass das dass die Investitionskosten und sind viel höher dafür hält so viel länger hinterher und bei denen konnte man es halt relativ schnell dahin hängen konnte das mit weniger Geld da hinhängen hat aber hinterher höre Betriebs,
aber das haben wir sind wir nicht gekommen und wir machen das einfach nicht in Deutschland bei uns ist es so dass wir momentan von der Planung hier das schon gar nicht also,
Dudu Pflanzen Landkreis für glasfaserverlegung und dann,
dann hast du so eine Handvoll kritische Stellen und da bist du dann mit Naturschutz zugange und mit der Bahn zugange und mit sonst was du gerne hast India Vorlaufzeit bevor du es anfangen ganze Glas also zulegen.
Ja aber wenn man es mal vielleicht von dieser technischen Ebene also klar ist das viel Aufwand das dauert lange das haben wir jetzt alle gemessen ich frage mich halt nur ist das was jetzt dann wirklich als Struktur entsteht auch wirklich Zukunft kompatibel oder brauchen wir nicht wirklich ein,
öffentlich betriebenes Netz so wie wir auch öffentlich betriebene Straßen haben damit danach auch der Zugang
sowohl für Provider als eben auch User ausgewogen statt
finden kann weil wenn das dann immer nur einer Firma gehört und die sind dann eben die firma die jetzt diesen Landkreis mit Glasfaser versorgt und dann diktieren Sie beliebige Preise ist ja auch keinem geholfen.
Aber egal so ist es ja nicht aber das Förderprogramm sieht anders aus im momentan so also momentan ist es so muss man einfach mal auch mal drüber reden ist vielleicht jetzt hier und nirgendwo ganz gut. Und das musst Du tun,
bin auch nur 1 € Förderung reinläuft dann muss das auf allen Netzebenen als auch in Access bereitstehen das heißt da kann jeder andere kann Leerrohr mieten kein Glasfaser mieten kann die Zugänge mieten und so weiteres,
anbietest bist du gleich aus nur die die Preise dafür für diese vorleistungsprodukt die werden von Anfang an ihm im Rahmen der Ausschreibung mit,
die sind entscheidendes Kriterium für die Vergabe wer dann das bekommt also kann sein ich davon ausgehen dass überall da wo gefördert gebaut wird hinterher auch mehrere Anbieter dann auf diesen Netzen sein werden da ist er das Problem wie groß sind die einzelnen Einheiten.
Dadurch ist es so wenn du einkaufen machen willst auf so einem Netz ein Landkreis soll man 40000 Haushalte oder je nach Landkreis 80000 oder was.
Das ist echt schwierig und meine ganzen Schnittstellen ein ganzen Prozess und ist darauf abzustellen sind die allerbeste sollte man eine so ein bisschen so eine vereinheitlichte Art von von Anschlüssen und und Netzzugang da drauf haben damit man dann auch einkaufen kann damit,
künftig einkaufen am heute einige Land,
Projekte die fertig sind wohl wirklich nur ein Anbieter da ist weil das für die anderen unglaublich schwierig ist da drauf tatsächlich dann dann Angebote zu machen oder das zu realisieren weil völlig inkompatible Technik verwendet,
willst du nicht hin ob das dann so ist wie.
Telekom das vorstellt oder sowas dass das dann ihre Vorgabe ist oder so eine nach der Methode das muss man natürlich mal diskutieren das sehen wir dann im Moment oben hier in den Bereich mit ewetel also also in Niedersachsen oben oder so,
da wo wo man sich jetzt zusammengetan hat und eine große Netzgesellschaft bauen möchte die dann für diese Fläche tut sich aber auch für alle dann noch auf alle vom gleichen Preisen.
Also welches ist jetzt so raus dass du eigentlich abgesehen davon dass es noch lange dauert so mit dem eingeschlagenen Weg geht schon ganz zufrieden bist und alles.
Ich bin nicht ganz und so dass das klingt ist völlig absurd aber ich bin nicht ganz unzufrieden damit was auf dem Land passiert weil da hat sich im Moment in FTTH aus,
die Frage mit ich selber seit drei Jahren bisland tingel und immer wieder Stelle ist das passiert in einigen Städten,
schon in den Städten ist es momentan so dass wir im auf die Kabelnetze gehen die wären auch eine Weile das ganz abbilden können also wir haben in den in den größeren Städten so gut wie überall Kabel und das wird auch bis zum,
Größenordnung Ende dieses Jahres so gut wie überall Gigabit anbieten also Gigabyte an.
The dicke Kabel TV.
Ja genau cable also ihr cable Katze ca TV und die wenn auch weiter skillen können die mir noch noch zwei drei vier Gigabyte oder sowas anbieten können aber das ist halt nicht,
was sind wieder Klaus Landefeld Amos ineko gut abnehmen wenn ich heute nach Asien gucke dann wird dort überall alles was gebaut wurde in den in den 2000ern jetzt schon auf 10 Gigabit umgebaut,
weil die Gigabyte Anschlüsse nicht mehr reichen also überall wo Glasfaser schon ist wird dort 10GB realisiert und das also 10 GB to the home ist ist der Standard der dort überall aufgebaut,
liegt noch nicht an sowas wie uhd TV und so weiter das manta bis 300 Megabits history.
Müssen langsam das in einleiten seid noch mal eine Frage zu,
time politischen Engagement du bist bist immer wieder als Sachverständiger eingeladen und berätst von daher sowie die muss das ja auch macht,
Bundestag und die Ausschüsse.
Hierbei auf mich hören ich nicht und auf dem Klaus haben die gehört weil wir kriegen jetzt erst gehört dir kriegen Gigabit.
Ja das ist die Frage also hören die dich wenn die auf dich.
Woher kommst du bis nach Zimmer zu dich verhört wird komischerweise zu überwachen wollen nämlich immer nicht erinnern das ist ja zu zu Breitbandausbau das was wird man schon gehört aber das liegt natürlich an der,
an an der Marktposition die man vertritt also wenn ich oder Kommentare abgibt oder sowas ähnliches dann ist natürlich so gut wie die ganze Branche drin wir haben,
hunderte von deutschen Netzanbietern die bei uns mit drin sind da wird man natürlich immer gehört,
Ernst steter Tropfen höhlt den Stein das also dass man jetzt umgestellt hat und sagt und wir müssen Glasfaser realisieren und die Förderung auch konsequent auf Glasfaser ausgelegt ist muss man ganz klasse sagen seit Mitte letzten Jahres ist alles nur noch als Glasfaser Förderband wird auch nur noch.
Ja aber willst du zu dem heißen Eisen.
Das gibt noch nicht Bereiche damit noch nicht gehört ja so Sicherheit oder sowas alt als die Sicherheitsthemen ja das ist da da wollen sie auch niemand hören ja das sind so die so diese Themen wie Hecken und so Online-Durchsuchung,
ja das sind Themen da da redet man gegen die Wand aber das ist leider auch eine Erfahrung aus 20 Jahren reguli also 20 Jahren Lobbying im Prinzip Innenbereich kriegt so gut wie immer was es was ihr wollt.
Weil da diese Totschlag Argumente mit ja wollen sie verantwortlich sein und so weiter das zieht leider in der Politik wenn man sich da hinstellt und sagt,
ja mache ich,
kein Problem sein aber da das ja eh keine Konsequenz hat also das ist eigentlich ein bisschen über das Problem wenn wenn mal was damit verbunden würde.
Wenn wenn etwas dann doch schief geht oder sowas aber das wenn er nie Konsequenzen hat rausgezogen also dieses dieses reine Argument zu sagen wir brauchen diese Maßnahme weil wenn wenn wir es nicht verhindern könnten wollen sie dann verantwortlich sein also das ist natürlich ein Argument.
Also funktioniert das ja alles nicht das ist ja es ist ja nicht zeig Bar dass das damit zusammenhängt und wir haben ja generell Moment so eine spannende Tendenz dass,
auch wenn im Sitzen umgesetzt schon drin steht ist musste evaluiert werden ob das überhaupt wirksam ist ob die Maßnahme funktioniert ob das alles irgendetwas,
dann wird es nicht getan wir machen die nächste Version des Gesetzes wer weiter und wieder die Befugnis und werde ohne dessen Evolution eigentlich vorlegt her und,
Eventim sind also was so überwachen zusammenbrechen liegt ja auch keiner vor das ist sehr gefordert das müsste die Regierung einig machen,
was passiert einfach nicht und wir machen aber neue neue neue Maßnahmen ohne dass ohne dass eigentlich jemand damit beschäftigt funktioniert es tut es was es gibt genug Studien die sagen die Maßnahmen sind in weiten Teilen völlig wirkungslos,
und hier hier vorgestern wieder.
Darknet geschichtliches aussehen oder so ja hoffentlich geht's auch ohne erweiterte Befugnisse und so warum sollte man das nicht.
Ist es eigentlich meine Frage wer macht was wie wird es angewendet welche welche Methoden werden verwendet und man braucht nicht immer neue Befugnisse.
Du hast eingangs gesagt dass sie die akademische Qualität im Netz anfangs etwas höher war als heute.
Ich glaube auch.
Aber wenn man wenn man jetzt dieses diese Idee wir bringen Deutschland ans Netz oder wie bauen überhaupt einen einen einen Netz und Internet in Deutschland wenn man das verfolgt und wie sich,
heute gesellschaftliche Phänomene ergeben die irgendwie zumindest nicht in wie ich mir vorstelle,
das Ergebnis sind was man sich davon gedacht hat ne wir bringen jetzt Internet dahin und dann dann können alle miteinander irgendwie Ideen austauschen und irgendwie,
qualifiziert miteinander diskutieren und wenn der wenn das Forum verbrannt ist weil zu viele Idioten drin sind und zu viele Claymores waren dann mach mal das nächste,
bis wir den Acker auch niedergebrannt haben so dazwischen so still so sehe ich in die Internetkommunikation ne,
und jetzt haben wir so viele komische Phänomene Content mäßig ne,
Internet vieles im Internet sende nur in eine Richtung diese diese zu der Rückkanal ist nicht mehr,
wird heute überhaupt nicht mehr vorgesehen dass du in beide Richtungen gleiche Bandbreiten hast viele Leute lassen sich berieseln wir haben Missbrauch an diesen freien Informationen.
Wie blickst du da drauf dass gerade schon diesen Zauberlehrling angesprochen bleibst du da so unkritisch oder denkst du vielleicht doch mal ein Upload Filter für Idioten langsamer einbauen oder so.
Also ich sehe dass ich seit Jahren so ein Problem damit was was sehr viel mit dem Renationalisierung zu tun hat also,
leider muss muss also jetzt einfach nur mein Blick da drauf sehr sehr viel hat begonnen als man wieder angefangen hat das,
in den Ländern zu diskutieren also als dieser internationale Effekt im Roxy weggebrochen ist und man man wieder Diskussion Sachen in in der Landessprache in was ich lokalen Zeichen setzen in sonst was nur dort statt und da passiert halt dann auch immer wieder diese Nationalismus dir dann da Ingolstadt,
dass ich in internationalen Gruppen eigentlich nie hat,
darstellen lassen ne also das ist so ein Effekt den den ich ganz klar beobachte die nicht schon aus den Neunzigern raus beobachtet habe der dann aber wieder ein bisschen eingefangen werden konnte aber mittlerweile im sehr sehr stark da ist und,
jetzt haben wir das aber auch das geht es nun schon weiter jetzt haben wir Regierungen an das tatsächlich sich ab,
Oppeln oder halt Filtersystem zu bauen dass man sagt wird wegen uns eigentlich nur noch primär innen stark kontrollierten Rahmenbruch unsere Regeln gelten so ungerecht Systeme gelten und so weiter und jeder.
Jeder aber sehr viele Regierung sind der Meinung sie können ihre eigenen Vorschrift machen was gesagt werden darf was was wie ausgedrückt werden darf man das beobachte ich mit sehr sehr großer Sorge,
in Deutschland noch nicht ganz da sind aber auch durchaus ossenpadd Tendenzen also,
hier so ein einachsiger was ging ja durchaus auch in diese Richtung also immer gesagt hat wir machen Regeln was was ihr gesagt wenn darf und wenn das dann am anderen Ende der Welt was gesagt wird das im deutschen Forum oder so dann dann gilt das da auch,
und das sind Themen die ich dich wirklich mit großer Sorge betrachte wo ich glaube dass das aber sie noch leider noch zunehmen wird in den nächsten Jahren und auch da muss ich leider sagen,
versagt die also die europäische Harmonisierung vollständig reden sollen wir börstinger market um uns das wollen das alles als 1 fahren aber dann machen wir trotzdem lauter nationale Gesetze was wie wo.
Gefiltert werden muss gesagt werden darf und so weiter und das einzig wo man sich dann überraschenderweise da einig ist sowas wie Upload Filter oder sowas nimmt sie immer noch überall machen muss ja,
das ist aber halt sehr stark getrieben von von nationalen Parlamenten hatten wir ja auch jetzt hier die das gesungen Anfang des Jahres weil dann irgendwie ein Heck oder sowas,
leg warmers einfach irgendwo unser Umgang mit der Zugangsdaten ist oder sowas ne,
und dann auf einmal brauchen wir dann weitere Gesetze oder müssen und wie weiter gehen und ist dann auch auf einmal breiten nationalen Alleingang zu machen aber wenn man betroffen ist ist man auf dem sich bereiten dass man alleine ein Zimmer Internationalisierung oder internationalen Vereinbarungen zu machen funktioniert nicht,
Sams übern Atlantik jahrelang versucht auch für Datenschutz mal für was zu machen das funktioniert einfach nicht sobald er die Rechtssystem aufeinander.
Das machen wir wir kommen voran was wir verbessern machen.
Was ist ein besser machen.
Ist ein Schlusswort jetzt überlegt.
Überleg dir gut oh mein Gott ja das ist wirklich ist wirklich schwierig zu sagen also mir zuviel Themengebiete angesprochen was muss man besser machen,
ich glaube insgesamt brauchen ein besseres Verständnis dafür was Digitalisierung für die Gesellschaft heißt wobei eigentlich hin müssen,
was ist was das für dich heißt das zu benutzen das auch immer zur Verfügung zu haben die gesellschaftliche Veränderungen so stark die dort,
dass das muss erstmal begriffen werden aber wenn ich mir überlege weiß das Beispiel Smartphones oder sowas ähnliches inwiefern wie kurzer Zeit wir wir welche gesellschaftliche Veränderungen hin.
Das hinbekommen hinbekommen erdulden das muss man diskutieren mussten das ist eigentlich dass das große Problem und so und ich glaube dass wir momentan der gesellschaftlichen Diskussion nicht weiter kommen solange man nicht wirklich verstanden hat wo das eigentlich hingeht,
jeder für sich selber etwas entwickeln konnte was ist für ihn heißt und und wir eigentlich kommunizieren möchte und wohin.
Wassermann positiver Ausblick.
Sollte realistische nein.
Ja ja ist ja in Ordnung,
suchen wenn Sie unser Format nicht aber wenn dann auch auf dem Selb stellen.
False positiv sein ich glaube wir schaffen das.
Wir schaffen das.
Vielen vielen Dank fürs Kommen Klaus dein Applaus.
Kann in bonn.
Ja Leute schön war's wir danken.
Peter und Mo und Kai die hier wieder Video und Wohnen unter Kontrolle gebracht haben.
Genau.
Und wir danken Leo Moritz und Christian und dem Familienduell Team der kriegt jetzt alle Namen nicht mehr auf die Reihe deswegen dem gesamten Familienduell,
und Leo Moritz und Christa dir was auf die Beine gestellt haben.
Die wollen uns Torten nicht mit brennenden nicht mit Kerzen Torten ne.
Ist das denn jetzt hier ach nee. An bist ja heißt warte mal ich bin jetzt mal kurz an mich.
Das ist eine Elle MP300 Torte.
Ja das ist sie hat sich gewaschen.
Und jetzt kann ich auch erzählen ich habe mit der ich wurde gewarnt dass irgendwas mit Torte ist und normalerweise wenn wenn irgendwas mit Torte ist rechne ich damit dass das auch irgendwas mit Gesicht ist.
Ich habe mich hier schon meine Schutzschirm bereitgelegt und mich notfalls für werden wir dank guten Gerechten.
Danke auch an roland für die tolle
graphische Begleitung wieder.
Danke an und jetzt wäre es gut gewesen wenn eine komplette Liste hätten ich will Alter.
Tobi Lilli Thaler Papillon.
WTC was Hausi und Bibor.
Echte herzliche Entschuldigung für die Person oder die Person die ich jetzt noch vergessen habe.
Mann immer vergisst.
Und einen besonderen großen Applaus bitte für Klaus Landefeld.
Und einen besonders großen Applaus bitte für Cécile Leonard.
Ja
und ein großen Dank an euch ihr immer so fleißig und genau zuhört kommentiert und das
motiviert auch wir haben so Phasen wo wir irgendwie manchmal das auch alles nicht mehr ertragen können oder uns auch mal nicht mehr ertragen können und das hilft auf jeden Fall immer sehr davon dieser Welle getragen zu werden und es ist total super und vielen Dank für eure unter
Sitzung und überhaupt.
Das war Logbuch Netzpolitik 300 vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.